I'm surprised they actually put this
video out Nancy Pelosi for some reason
had a film crew on her on January 6 and
then when they start seeing people
entering the capitol grounds Nancy
Pelosi says this is my moment the moment
I've been waiting for trespassing on the
capitol grounds and then threatens to
strike Donald Trump and go to jail and I
just I'm really surprised they thought
this would be good for them
the question is why was Nancy Pelosi why
did she have a film crew with her okay
maybe just her daughter and her daughter
was filming sure why did Nancy Pelosi
say this is what I've been waiting for
she was waiting for that like she
thought that was gonna happen she's
waiting for that to happen she wanted it
to happen that's really really weird
isn't it you add all these pieces
together and that's all I have to say is
it's very weird but we'll talk we'll
pull up this story and then I wonder if
it'll actually criminal criminally
charge her for threatening the president
although I really don't think so
obviously
and then my friends we actually have uh
some really interesting media Scuttle
but this one's for all you Trump
supporters out there according to
internal rumors Jim Acosta is about to
be fired from CNN because he's a uh anti
he's an anti-trump lightning rod and
they're trying to clean up their image
so reportedly or I should say new uh
some personalities are saying that he is
on the way out so we'll talk about that
plus a whole bunch of other stuff it's
Friday boy we have an ensemble cast for
all of you tonight joining us to talk
about well actually I'm sorry I gotta do
that go to timcast.com first go to
timcast.com become a member when you're
a member you make the company like run
you know you as the members are
basically the fuel for the journalists
and all the stuff we do and the
uncensored shows you guys know all of
this stuff don't you go to timcast.com
sign up support our work Joel oh yeah
like the video subscribe to the channel
share the share with your friends
joining us to talk about this and more
we've got Jessica Vaughn hi who are you
well I am a Playboy Playmate who was a
life lifetime Democratic voter and I was
um dark red pilled by the shutdowns and
so now I'm just taking my audience on
the Journey of my discoveries about the
actual way that reality is constructed
yeah that's cool yeah as soon as you
turn off CNN I guess things start to
change yes and MSNBC and joining us
she's returned I have it's Lydia it's
true Lydia leiterman has returned thank
you so much for having me back even
though I shunned you guys by leaving I'm
so sorry I'll never do I'm just kidding
I'm just here as a guest I'm excited I'm
watching surge carefully as he presses
buttons in my place he's doing a great
job it's been a really fun job she's not
gonna be able to help it she's going to
be like critiquing surge the whole time
as a guest and uh also joining us is the
one and only Rusty Cage
hello I'm a musician and YouTuber I've
been on YouTube for about 12 years and I
think I'm partially responsible for the
corruption of gen Z but I'm not quite
sure probably yeah and and actually I
think you may you may be um one of the
original what's the right way to put it
you freaked YouTube out maybe yeah I
mean I definitely uh over the years have
tried to get as close as possible to
Breaking terms of service without
Crossing it but I always end up doing
that anyways I can't really say what I'm
doing right now on YouTube
[Laughter]
yeah Rusty cool man thanks for hanging
out and then of course the T-shirt
vendor himself Linda oh yeah I have
returned you're already causing trouble
here what is This Woman's history month
that's right I'm excited to mansplain
this entire show
my name is the shirt that I'm wearing
today is a representation of schmiegel
or Dr fauci uh adoring his of course a
ring of attention if you like the shirt
you could get it on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here thank you so much
for having me good to see you Linda you
came back Luke I have to say that's a
good t-shirt and I don't think I've ever
said that before so you have it nice
work thank you finally keep going yeah
of course start just pressing the
buttons that's true yeah when I remember
to do it pardon me I'm looking at the
Monitor and I'm just like hey wait
that's not Rusty it's chilling that's me
we brought Lydia back to audit year
Behavior that's right no pressure secret
shopper he's not supposed to know she
almost sat in your chair when she I did
she just walked in and I was like oh
yeah this is where oh no no not this
time it's not your chair anymore I know
it's gone all right here's the first
story Pelosi said she wanted to punch
Trump as January 6 Riot began video
shows I want you to listen to that
headline real quick as January 6th Riot
began because we're going to use the
language of the mainstream media to
paint a picture for you so the riot is
beginning okay what else did Nancy
Pelosi say I hope he comes I want to
punch him out Pelosi says in response
this is my moment I have been waiting
for this for trespassing on the capitol
grounds I want to punch him out and I'm
going to go to jail and I'm going to be
happy says Nancy Pelosi
so let's just uh
hold on there a minute what does it mean
when someone says this is my moment I've
been waiting for this it means you knew
that it was coming it also implies you
wanted it to happen you're like this is
the moment I've been waiting for like my
it sounds like you it's something you
want to happen or she's an opportunist
and this was the perfect time for her to
pretend like she's some heroic figure in
politics yeah but but when she said for
trespassing on the capitol grounds and
the Washington Post says as Riot began
that implies she wanted the riot she
wanted to exploit it and she had a film
crew with her ready to go as it was
happening like I just I'm sorry you
piece this together and it's a woman
saying here's my camera crew filming me
this is what I've been waiting for for
the trespassing
it sounds like she knew it was gonna
happen yeah if she wants to go to jail
why can't she just go to jail Nancy
Pelosi yeah she could that's true very
true it's because her husband always
drives yeah yeah she wasn't with him
when he crashed though was she nope no
no no no but you know another good point
too is if she wants to go to jail why
doesn't she just buy the stocks instead
of having her husband yeah right yeah
well and it was such like Insider Trader
Behavior to have like her kid there
filming not somebody else or whatever
just like her kid because imagine all
the other great footage that her child
is gonna have because obviously they
knew that there was something going to
be happening that day for her to have
premeditatedly have her child come in to
film all of this so I'm sure her kid's
going to have a great documentary it's
going to put her on a map about all the
footage she has That's Unique for you
know this terrible event that happened
on the you know the day yeah I have a
feeling that they're going to say
something like she was just their phone
it's no big deal like people are there
filming this stuff all the time time you
know whatever
oh yeah we gotta stay close to our mics
oh yeah just pull it up a little bit
yeah right you're gonna look right at it
right up in it there you go well love it
ladies Luke what a violent unhinged
human being and she's known for getting
Insider tips so uh what's going on here
of course you know a lot of people will
have their theories here but uh a lot of
people did see a lot of trouble coming
our way on January 6th and for some
reason they got rid of security and
limited the amount of people that would
respond to a big emergency that they saw
coming there was even Facebook pages and
Facebook events literally detailing hey
there's going to be you know rallies and
people attempting to go into the capital
on January 6th so the intelligence
agencies the government agencies all
knew it was coming Nancy Pelosi the
queen of insider trading didn't see this
coming no she did she said she was
waiting for it that's the official story
is that she didn't see this coming well
that's you know makes sense it's
contradicted by her own statements the
moment I've been waiting this is my
moment I've been waiting for this for
trespassing on the capitol grounds
maybe she did like I'm sorry that's her
saying she knew it was gonna happen well
maybe they're responsible for Designing
the entire day right I mean the
conspiracy theory is like why why
weren't there police there were very few
why did police open the doors AOC said
this and you know I'm sorry I have to
call out what an unhinged conspiracy
theorist can you believe her Alexandria
Cortez coming out and saying that police
were helping the rioters well we know
that's true but
I I don't know so I gotta experience a
theorist I gotta ask wasn't Nancy Pelosi
the one who wanted
crew served equipment machine gun was it
before or after I can't remember after
was it after afterwards she called for
uh machine gun turrets to be installed
at the U.S Capitol no to mold down
humans it was before wasn't it I thought
I believe it was afterwards I might be
wrong but we could look that up right
now and find out why can't all the other
governments that we've taken over they
all had them at their fortresses so she
knew the fence was coming yeah yeah it's
uh it's kind of interesting to see it's
almost like I feel like you're trying to
trying to allude to like the 40 chest
moves that you could be making in the
background we have no idea what could be
happening it was afterwards when they
sent the National Guard to sleep inside
of the capital if you remember that [ __ ]
and she was on record saying afterwards
like we need machine gun turrets here in
order to protect everyone and to mow
down those crazy Grand mamas maybe she
had just invested in a machine gun
company
planting the seed
this was before uh probably yeah so I
have the story from CNS acting DHS
Deputy deputy secretary Pelosi wanted
crew manned machine guns in Washington
that was rejected I think uh what they
were saying is that because of the BLM
riots in in 2020 because of the the 529
Insurrection Pelosi was like okay with
this thing coming up we need you know
crew served machine guns could you just
imagine if like Pelosi and the Democrats
actually got those things mounted and
they're like on swivels and they're like
just like mowing people down like the
funny thing about this story is that
Pelosi doesn't realize bullets keep
going
so just imagine the foundation the first
floor of every building just peppered
with what kind of bolts do these someone
someone super chatted us like 303 or
something that said I don't know what
kind of bolts they would use for these
you know 50 cal Maybe 50 cal fully auto
no that's like anti-material rounds but
yeah here's the story you know Nancy
Pelosi wanted machine guns she would
quickly rewrite that event it would be a
massacre and uh it would somehow turn
into her being the hero again
the most corrupt politician hmm
yeah she's definitely up there like I I
feel like she's
non-partisan she's always going to be in
politics uh even after her uh her flesh
body dies
didn't it already happen so like yeah
after she ages out we'll call it she's
80. the the shadow monster that
possesses the reanimated corpse will
emerge and then possess a new member of
Congress okay yeah and that's how it
plays out uh I actually I have some
Insider information oh that uh leads
some individuals to believe Pelosi
expects not to be in Congress this this
coming term really yeah
I can't say much more than that because
the the sources are still currently
working on the story but based on
internal goings on I can say it's
seeming like she doesn't think she'll be
in office does she think she's going to
retire or is she going to depart voted
out mortal coil shouldn't be voted out
yeah I think she's I think she's well
they're not voting out retiring I'm
sorry I'm sorry I think okay uh of the
speakership she's not going to get the
speakership she may run she'll probably
win but I think she might retire
actually because that's the only way you
get someone like Pelosi out she chooses
to leave you know I'm almost terrified
to see who is going to replace her
because I don't know in in San Francisco
or Speaker of the House who's going to
be the speaker of the house yeah exactly
they're probably assassinate Putin and
then put her in she's probably gonna run
Russia as well
you know it'll be really cool though it
would be cool just like I want you to
imagine that right now you fall asleep
and you wake up and it's 10 years later
and you don't know why you're doing a
coma and you turn the TV on and there's
cyber Pelosi with like machine parts on
her face and then she's looking into the
camera with like one glowing red camera
aren't you like hello people so wow I am
currently reclaimed with Russia for
everyone
that's a good Nancy Pelosi yeah that's
good right this is his best impression
my biggest fear was that I would die
before her yeah
it would just be something on my
deathbed like oh no what did I do wrong
she's still I mean she's gonna be a
hundred no I think she might be retiring
I think she might be I don't know though
I think even if who who's going to who
could replace her that would be better
considering the district it's San
Francisco there's there's poop
everywhere and the people are just
walking around looking at it and it's so
bad they created a poop Department I I
just don't see Improvement you know you
know in South Park there was a big
campaign for turd sandwich so you know
it might not be that far off to see you
know an actual turd sandwich be voted on
the election that I would vote for it we
might actually get to that point where
people just like they're fed up yeah and
they're like the Republican candidates a
ham sandwich and they're like whatever
sounds great it's better than the
Democrat I mean you look at look at John
fetterman the dude is is he has brain
damage and I mean that in the literal
sense I'm not trying to be disrespectful
he actually had a stroke and now he
cannot process sounds he doesn't know
what people are saying to him well what
better indicator that it's your time to
shine than like the Joe Biden presidency
popular as this it's like if you're
incompetent please step up to the plate
this is your time well also if she if
she doesn't have a lot of power and
she's not going to be the majority
leader if she's going to be my the
minority leader if Republicans take the
house she's probably going to be like ah
there's not enough information for me to
get here to make more money off of this
she's 81 years old she's been in in the
house for 33 years that's a lot of time
in in government that's a lot of
information that you could squeeze for
your own personal benefit there's a
limit to anything so she's like you're
not going to Don Lemon me and put me on
a Morning Show
no man could just imagine The View
with her oh gosh you have you know
Whoopi Goldberg ask her a question
it's just a problem for this country I
disagree I think that the view is the
best place for Nancy to retire to I can
imagine she would fit right in she's got
the right look she's got the right
following and she has all the
connections I love this idea she'd fire
the existing crew and be like my
daughter and yeah
my uh one of my favorite Family Guy
jokes is they're watching The View and
it's all of the women and they're
sitting there and they're going on
and they're all blocking each other and
then all of a sudden one of the women
goes like burn she sits up and there's
an egg on the couch but then just to
butter this joke perfectly the camera
Zooms in on the egg and then you hear
Little Women barking even more and I'm
like that was just great like I get the
joke that they're clucking but then to
show the egg and zoom in on it and his
Masterpiece I don't think that's fair
because the view doesn't actually
produce anything eggs are valuable you
can eat them the view gives us nothing
nothing
yeah you know chickens chickens have
have actually you know look I think the
view is detrimental yeah so this this
low low information show it was it was
fascinating I saw I saw a clip where
apparently uh Whoopi Goldberg was
talking to the her co-star from Sister
Act
and the show is such low information
that the actress didn't even know they
were doing another one Whoopi Goldberg
was like yeah we're getting our
subscript at the end of the month and
she's like huh what I was like wow
that's really impressive like you're
actually I don't maybe maybe she's not
in the movie but I'm like you you were
in the first two and you don't even know
that's how low information the view is
the people who are involved in the movie
don't even know what's happening I hate
brilliant of you I hate the view because
it it convinces women that they're
watching the news
with the news what they're actually
doing is just demoing how to gang up on
conservatives yeah I mean yeah but
that's all the show is yeah I love how
they just they have these weird token
conservatives that aren't really
conservative that just agree with like
I'm a conservative but you know what I
agree Joe Biden is great and it's like
who are these people they're the
feminine version of the Lincoln project
you know those balling guys look like
they're a Viagra commercial and Rogaine
commercial these are those ladies I'm
gonna don't the Lincoln project like
kids yeah they're sure too a little too
much children wasn't that like what was
up with that that was like a thing where
like
they were sending gross messages to
underage boys I think oh it was yeah are
they mad at Trump because Trump was was
ragging on pitos I think so that's
probably it I remember when Trump was
doing that debate and they asked him
about q and like pizza gate stuff and
then Trump was like well you know they
think I'm you know I'm fighting against
it so you know what's wrong with that
that's probably why the Lincoln project
got mad not that conspiracy theory is
real but that it was like it was a real
insult to the pedo community so Lincoln
project naturally was was just offended
most affected all right I got good news
my friends we got this uh this uh series
of tweets from John Nicosia he tweeted
on October 11th cryptically scoop
another big name about to exit CNN
Discovery executive he does not have a
place in the new CNN he reminds us of
the Zucker period we are looking to move
far from the only reason he is still on
the air was not to look like we were
cleaning house for political reasons
right after the closing John says I
agreed not to report the name until the
end of the week
the person this discovery executive was
talking about is Jim Acosta CNN like
they did when I reported about stelter
being let go will be uh will be to
defend will be to defend the person
that's what the network PR people do
keep in mind many of the recent people
let go had big support within the
network and more
but did not fit into the middle ground
Vision CNN is being pushed into since
Acosta was the was the main Trump
lightning rod between the old CNN and
the new owners Future Vision he will
either go quick or with a lot of
internal pushback stay tuned one
important thing that this executive
wanted to stress is they are nowhere
near done and Acosta won't be the last
of the Old Guard to go but this takes
time and they're getting an incredible
amount of internal pushback from people
who want to stay a resistance Network oh
I love that quote a resistance Network
here's what I think is happening I think
that the executive is leaking to John
with approval from the company really
because they can't come out and
disparage the employees people like
Acosta probably for contractual reasons
but they desperately want people like
our audience to know they are cleaning
house and trying to to fix this problem
so here is exactly how you do it
I just think that there's any saving CNN
at this point and also who is worse Jim
Acosta or Brian stelter oh Jim Acosta I
think so yeah but they're both bad for
different reasons there's no saving CNN
sorry guys uh uh you know look I know
there's a lot of people over at CNN that
are thinking they can clean this up you
can't it's like you know when when you
get skunked it's like you you smell
lingers maybe CNN you can take a bath in
some tomato soup or whatever it is
you're supposed to do I don't know but
it ain't coming off it's it's really
stuck in there you know actually here's
a better example you ever you ever see
an apartment after like some old person
dies but they were a smoker since they
were 20. and everything is just caked in
nicotine and it's yellow that's CNN
right now so look by the time you gut
and Rehab the place it's a toe it's a
total rehab it's not even gonna look
like CNN anymore you might as well just
call it something different and build it
from the ground up well they probably
will do that and also if they raise the
new generation knowing that that's new
Norm then CNN's not going to seem so
radical or crazy or biased and so if
they grow up in that smoke uh tattered
house they're gonna say oh this is
reality this is normal for us yeah it's
normal when your teachers are yeah right
into your face yeah that's that's how I
view CNN basically and and it's not like
they had a good record beforehand I mean
they were started by Ted Turner who of
course is a known eugenicist that I also
believe that there was too many people
in this world he of course was using the
network to push his agenda and you know
Linda you say should they be saved
absolutely no hell no no no let them
wither away and and and no no no no no
no no let them ride off peacefully into
the sunset with smiles on their faces I
hope that in Jim acosta's retirement he
lives a long healthy happy life and it
won't matter because he's not on TV
anymore bye-bye did you see Cuomo's new
show ratings were like 40 000. yeah CNN
lost uh this is according to the Forbes
70 of their key demo within the last few
months I did not ask CNN should be saved
I asked if it could be saved I don't
think it should be saved and I think
Tim's right their reputation is way too
far gone but I respect if maybe they
want to like change their name and kind
of go in like a completely different
direction like retire for two years NCC
news for cable channels yeah we're sorry
News Network we're destroying this
country
trustworthy sources yeah I was I was
always uh uh on our knees apologizing
please forgive us I was always a bit
partial to the cable channel name msmbs
you know because because if they did
that that I'd be that'd be pretty funny
and I bet you know they're kind of
owning it so uh you know I watch because
then when they come out and they're just
saying things like it's very
presidential of the president to bomb
another country and it just says msmbs
underneath them I'd be like oh okay
checks out yeah msnbs I actually would
appreciate that level of self-awareness
from a news site I think that would be
cool they should just uh brand
themselves as like uh State media just
go straight for like what it is yeah
American Pravda yeah that has a nice
ring to it too you know yeah didn't uh
Elon Musk buy the website American
Pravda and then he never did anything
with it yeah he did sounds like
something James O'Keefe would buy it's
not his book yeah that is his book yeah
yeah but uh Elon Musk bought the site
and just never did anything with it not
yet not yet it's been like six years
though so hopefully he does he seems
like a pretty busy guy huh what's it
gonna do
I don't know man CNN is going down in
flames it's kind of a good thing Cuomo
tried launching a new shows at news
nation and then just nobody watches
they're just the it's not so much Old
Guard it's just kind of like
it's hard to build up a big show these
days period let alone being really awful
people that are obviously lying to you
you know like if you go on TV every day
and you're just like Sky's green because
uh it is good luck people are just gonna
be like why would I watch this so you've
already got people they can choose any
news network they want they can choose
any YouTube video they want and then you
add on top of it that you're a bunch of
really awful partisans who are lying
relentlessly it's no wonder their key
demo viewerships in the gutter and
unfortunately it's kind of no wonder why
they're 60s with 67 plus age bracket is
actually still fairly High it is low but
I feel bad for those people who
genuinely think CNN is news
maybe they can keep CNN but like make it
mean something different
like uh corporate non-news
like uh not news yeah they could switch
over and do the MSNBC where they're like
the American cheese product of news
networks where they're not actually news
their only opinion then they could
slowly shift to more moderate take
that's what they were trying to do yeah
yeah didn't work so what replaces it
what you know if people aren't getting
their their their uh the narrative if
people are well I'll put it this way
there's no unified culture anymore as I
often say we used to watch a handful of
news channels a handful we had we had
like five networks and that's why
everybody believed the same thing now
you've got all different channels all
different shows people can watch whoever
they want so everyone's going to be
thinking completely different things and
then where does where does that bring us
to what's the end result of that CNN
plus it's a crazy idea guys but I think
if CNN decentralizes and and does online
content for paid subscription I think
they're going to have a great success
with it they should try it what if
they're sacrificing CNN and closing it
essentially to like boost MSNBC or
something because you know how all the
audience is so deluded down over all the
the liberal media choices but fox is
doing so well in Leeds and all this
because there's only the one maybe
they're trying to just consolidate that
down
um there's not enough people watching
television in the classic way anymore
they'd have to get rid of ABC NBC CBS et
cetera et cetera you know yeah but
actually it would be really cool like
they're talking about firing Jim
CNN hear me out I got a big idea this
would be huge it'd be huge huge news
shut down just no more CNN gone let the
brand Sunset and then everyone can leave
and uh you know well they could keep
their International versions like
because other people in other countries
don't have the tainted opinion of CNN no
just let it go let's do that I mean CNN
like they're pretty much almost dead
already no one's really watching them so
we should hold them memorial service for
them just like a mock comedic one where
like it was and we we go around the room
say our favorite moments that we had
with CNN mine was when the BLM
protesters were trying to burn down
their offices when they were talking
about how great the protests were that's
my favorite uh if you guys want to go
around the table uh feel free to tell us
your favorite memory of your News
Network I felt like that was so fitting
that they went right up to their
doorstep and they were like we're
ruining it to you here we go my favorite
one of my favorite moments
um man this brings back memories you
guys you know I remember when there was
this viral meme of Anderson Cooper Waist
Deep in water
and then the the wide shot shows a guy
standing on the road in Anderson's just
like in the water for no reason
giant beer or something Anderson
Cooper's just like oh so much wind and
water that was definitely like a
formative memory of going oh all right
this guy's full of [ __ ] right fake news
yeah but they win an award you know yeah
there's more there's more there's Don
Lemon in the black hole come on I know
you guys have some come on come on
you're right let me let me let me do
this one there was oh man you guys the
memories this was uh Don Lemon was doing
a panel the Malaysian Airline went
missing this is this is an example of
like why CNN became what it is why did
CNN go hyper partisan because when the
Malaysian airplane went missing they
didn't know what to do so they had Round
the Clock coverage of a plane that was
missing and it was just re like people
watched it and then Don Lemon is talking
to a group of people and he says no
we're getting a lot of questions about
you know black holes and I know it's
Preposterous but Mary is it Preposterous
and then someone goes you know even a
small black hole would swallow the whole
universe so and I was like wow a small
one would eat the whole universe I
didn't realize there must not be a
supermassive black hole that's under the
Milky Way galaxy we were wrong about
that and that was mainstream news and it
was funny because when I called it out
and a lot people kept saying Yeah but
come on Tim he's just he's just making a
show and I'm like this is the most
trusted name in news asking a guest and
the guests spewing out the most insane
garbage ever ah that was that one was
great I actually remember where I was
when that happened that's how core it
was to me my personal favorite that
we're all for getting is actually fiery
but mostly peaceful that was yeah
I wasn't sure
certainly classic stuff yeah and then
all those all those uh wonderful
memories from New Year's yeah oh yeah
when they all got drunk and accidentally
told the truth that was really fun too I
remember that there's Russia gate those
guys oh man wow there's you know calling
Trump a Nazi for like four years that
was that was incredible Brave that was
bold what was it like 60 000 times or
something Trump sued and he said that
they called him Hitler like tens of
thousands what was that discredited
lawyer that they propped up said it was
going to be the next leader of the
democratic party yeah look at us just
old friends laughing about the old times
and you know I'm gonna miss them so
CNN's probably just gonna Rebrand or uh
shift all their leadership and whoever
controls it yeah what are they shifting
over to is it well they brought in a new
guy Discovery bottom I guess and they
got this uh what's his name Chris Licht
is that who's doing it great last name
by the way and they're firing all of the
crackpots okay
I want to tell you guys one of my
favorite moments it was when they fired
Brian stelter oh yeah and Don Lemon yeah
yeah well Don Lemon just gonna move to a
Morning Show yeah he got demoted my
favorite Don Lemon moment was when he
tried really hard to pin that most
recent hurricane pain on global warming
and the NOAA guy was like yeah no that
was not a real thing I had personal
experience how can we forget the
incredible Lubin tubing all right
come on guys you're right come on you're
right seriously that's a good one is
this what it's actually like like after
the funeral when everyone's remembering
the good times absolutely like I
remember you know you know Jimmy he
threw me a beer and that and I never I
never realized it'd be the last Beauty
threw me and now we're just like oh CNN
they made up fake news that one time and
it's the last time we're ever gonna hear
it yeah I mean we're being awfully
generous for a funeral of like a piece
of [ __ ]
yeah I think that um you could easily
say that my favorite part about CNN was
their titling reliable sources from the
most trusted name in news there's also a
show called like No Lie by some guy who
totally makes stuff up I'm like this is
totally the reliable sources after Brian
Selter leaves I love how just like
they're so obvious with what they're
doing this show is called the only true
show with facts and we're Fair on the
most trusted News Channel that's right
we should we got to do that with timcast
we got to call we gotta make a tagline
like the only honest factual reporting
anywhere ever from the most trusted name
in news and commentary that is fair and
balanced
that's good what's msnbc's tagline
no idea crazy woman thinks Russia's taxo
plasma lady going nuts
there's so many more moments coming up
that I just have to bring up especially
with the doctor that that went on The
Joe Rogan show and then and then said
that Joe first originally he said Joe
Rogan was taking horse Pace went on The
Joe Rogan show he said he wasn't taking
horse pace and then Don Lemon bullied
him to say he was taking horse Pace
again so Sanjay Gupta San Diego that
doctor oh when they hit the brain how
can we forget about that one oh my
goodness oh man the memories you guys oh
my God so uh they're all coming back do
you know about this one no the cannibal
CNN reporter that sounds oh yeah
Aslan
he's like a religious scholar and
commentator had a show and he ate a
piece of human brain right right he went
to uh there's another country like yeah
India I think okay I think I thought it
was a tribe in afghanist like a super
isolated tribe I thought it was Heroes
India yeah it was Hindu yeah and he sat
down and they cooked a piece of brain
and he ate it and I think I I think he
went insane from it I really do you got
Kuru is that what it's called yeah yeah
the shakes you eat the shakes yeah you
eat a human brain did it get smarter no
no
oh no I think you know I I think it's
psychologically destroyed him
probably yeah you do in the moment and
then later you go holy [ __ ] well well
but here's why this is around the time
that Vice was presumably big everybody
thought Vice was like the biggest thing
ever and they really wanted to emulate
this and so they CNN tried making this
very vice-like show and they're like
we're gonna send this guy this religious
guy to go explore these religions and
he's gonna eat brain and he probably
felt like he had to do it yeah he's
sitting there in the moment the
producers are like eat the brain eat it
we're gonna get all the ratings and he's
like and then he eats it and then he's
like I did it are you happy though and
then they canceled his show and so I can
imagine he's like sitting in his living
room and he's like looking at his hands
and he's like
[Music]
that's who he is now he's a cannibal by
the way yeah yeah I've had I've had
people tell me that Reza aslan's not a
cannibal and then I was like what's a
cannibal
it's a it's a human who ate who eats
human right yeah and then I had someone
say to me he's not a cannibal he ate
human one time and I was like oh so if
someone murdered someone one time
they're not a murderer I mean if you
smoke crack once you're not a crackhead
your crackhead is a reference you're not
an addict but a crack a crackhead is a
reference someone who continually does
it right a murderer right oh yeah yeah
you're right he just murdered one guy he
only murdered one guy you know and and
so yeah you're a murderer then dude some
people have argued they're like if you
steal once are you a thief 10 years
later
and it's like good questions you know
okay okay so maybe there will be a
certain point where he's no longer
accountable but that's up for personal
discretion as to when you feel he's no
longer in my personal opinion he still
is because he's still actively eating
human brains but I don't have any proof
it might be
just my opinion what if that's what the
reason he went crazy you guys ever see
uh was it iZombie
yeah it's like it's someone look it up
there's like a woman and then she gets
bitten and then the way the show works
is that if you're if you've been
infected and you eat brains you don't
degrade into a Mindless zombie you stay
as like a conscious Lucid zombie I guess
what oh yeah you can see part of this
[ __ ] yeah is that the show yeah it's
called iZombie and I have to say the
favorite favorite thumbnail I ever made
was Reza ozon eats a brain eats someone
else's brain and loses his own mind or
something like he ate someone else's own
maybe like after that moment I just want
you to picture this you know he's like
he comes back he's like he's he's he
feels psychologically traumatized from
having done this but the next day
the steak just doesn't taste the same oh
no yeah the candy bars don't have that
sweet Feeling Anymore the cheesecake
just no longer lingers and he starts
getting pale and he's like what's
happening to me and then he calls us he
goes to a butcher and he's like let me
try the pork and he goes and he cooks it
doesn't work for him he's like maybe the
elk and then finally the guy goes hey
buddy I know what you need I know what
you want I know what you need call my
guy here's the address and then he goes
to this address and he's like what is it
he looks up and it says New York City
Morgan he's like no
and then he goes in there and that's it
that's Russ's history dude this reminds
me of that it's always sunny episode
where they are tricked into eating
raccoons someone tells them it's you and
me and they're like oh my gosh I guess
we have to go to the morgue I think
that's what's going on they should have
done like the Army Hammer move and like
just have him go sell timeshares in the
Caribbean because once you're a known
cannibal I guess that's what you go do I
guess he's like super rich though anyway
so like I don't know if he really cares
but I have to be honest you know I was
like I I uh jokes aside I was thinking
about how he ate human brain and I was
just thinking like
yo if it were me
and I did I would be destroyed because
that you could never return like there
are certain things in your life that you
can never undo and like forever he will
have been that guy who ate human brain I
think I would do it eat him and brain
yeah just to try it in like a religious
ceremony you'll get Kuro is that what
just like a religious ceremony like
that'd be kind of weird but that's what
it was you'll get the shakes yeah but
that's like a significant amount of
brains yeah so you do have to eat a
certain amount it was charred like it
was cooked really down what was his I do
remember this story but I don't remember
his reaction to it did he just like he
got beat up the the the cannibals beat
the crap out of him they left him upside
the head yeah the eclipse on C on
YouTube my channel was getting
demonetized for just talking about stuff
and and breaking down geopolitical news
right and YouTube was like yeah we can't
allow this this is not okay this is not
family friendly content when I don't
swear didn't curse was it going crazy I
was literally like okay here's the
here's the national resources here's the
the larger conflict here's the history
no no no that's not okay CNN Headline
News
promoted by CNN in the algorithm here we
human brains that was A-Okay and and
literally Aslan was getting beat up by
these guys that forced and then he was
like okay I'll eat it I'll eat it and
and they were abusing him during the it
was it was the most craziest thing that
you could ever imagine violated so many
terms and services but of course that
didn't matter to you that of course was
promoting this utter nonsense and
craziness so I don't know if you want to
pull up the video but I don't know if we
can we might get a strike on it because
CNN also uh filed a fake copyright
strike against me a couple years ago and
took my ability down from live streaming
I had a live show before I had to take
it down for a month because CNN took
down me talking about the State of the
Union which they said it was there
somehow and I was like these lines we're
gonna we're gonna issue uh we're gonna
do a segment someone just super chatted
this to us and we'll talk about it's
Friday we're having a good time Tulsi
gabbard oh this is her verified Twitter
account she tweeted March 18 2015 World
economic forum is that what a WF I am
honored to be selected as 2015 young
young Global leader voices representing
Hawaii amongst leaders from around the
world and then the young global leaders
responded congrats that's we're excited
to have you join the ygl 2015 Community
someone tagged me in it a couple days
ago someone's saying that that's not no
it is it's it's ours verified follows me
you know
yeah yeah so uh this is a correction
because the other day you know so when
um Dan Crenshaw people were highlighting
he was on the world economic Forum list
he told me he's like I have nothing to
do with that they just it's an editorial
thing like they pick it what am I you
know and I was like oh okay I get it his
voting record would suggest otherwise
yeah but definitely in lockstep but this
is the thing we we saw yeah I saw
screenshots of Tulsi responding to this
specifically saying this wasn't you know
something that I did and saying the same
thing that Grant Dan Crenshaw was well
here you go bro I want to read it well
this is from 2010 2015. there's recent
ones with her saying no no I didn't I
didn't you know do anything for this
they just kind of put my name this tweet
says 2015. no I mean I mean that's true
yeah that's true she's saying she was
selected it doesn't mean that she did
anything but she at the time she was
like this is a good thing
so did she know who the w e f was like I
don't know what her opinion of it is now
she's also a member of the Council on
Foreign Relations which is a far off
more Sinister organization when it comes
to American geopolitics and of course
the world economics do they eat brains
probably who knows I got I got
personally kicked out of that
organization you were a member no uh as
as a member of press I covered many of
their I covered many of their events and
I had uh Schmidt's uh girlfriend
literally call me and she was like
radowski no more no it's not happening
you're not allowed to come here stop
coming here because I would come there
just legitimately have conversations
with them about their bigger plans and
agenda and you know obviously resting
like that did you know that Luke's been
no
this joke again it's not a joke that was
a statement of fact yeah he's been to FC
Charles yeah but people think I'm I'm a
like a dirty man people think I'm a
Kevin Spacey like a really exciting like
time where you actually got to go on the
island I saw
to random people they're like oh man
he's probably a dirty guy he's probably
a bad guy because people immediately
assume that like he flew with Epstein
right yeah no I mean how else do you get
there yeah you went on the Little League
oh he's not you snuck into an island
onto an island onto an island he got in
a speed boat after the raid and then
jumped on and started filming everything
yeah I don't think this is really fair
because that was actually super cool and
he used a drone to like document
everything that had no he didn't do the
Drone did you there was Drone footage of
of someone that looked exactly like
Epstein after he allegedly died showing
him on that island no uh there's a
random person that that is on on those
islands and he flies a drone and he gets
all the information he released one day
footage of what looks like exactly like
Jeffrey Epstein after he died after the
FBI raid and I was like I gotta
investigate this so I got you know a
boat and we went on the island to
investigate if he was still alive I
thought you had a drone when you went
there uh we did but but we uh we used
some of the footage but but the the
footage that is very famous online is
done by someone else an anonymous
account who hasn't been identifying
himself who has been flying the drones
and documenting the destruction of that
island and all the different facilities
and all the different stuff on there
it's a huge island I mean I was on there
for about 30 40 minutes and I was
running most of the time I still only
saw half of the island wow they had
full-on uh you know medical trucks
full-on huge construction vehicles there
it was a huge there was a doorway on the
floor for some reason uh we didn't know
where it led to uh we got to put a Sex
Dungeon
for sure but but we can do build up put
it up
but there's entire like EMTs on that
island helicopter pads everywhere weird
symbology everywhere so it was it was
every time people say symbology it
reminds me of Boondock Saints oh yeah
and then I'm just like inspired to
Willem dafo and go symbolism symbology
symbolism potatoes
I got that wrong a couple times I saw
someone call me out before that just a
couple days ago so I'm like all right
I have to apologize to Chris Tucker the
actor because when I was reading a list
of all the people that had gone to
Epstein Island uh Chris Tucker was on
there and I was like the actor and I was
like oh man but it's not the same Chris
Tucker it is because Chris Tucker was on
uh with Kevin Spacey with Bill Clinton
when they took Jeffrey Epstein's Island
over to Africa no no they took Jeffrey
Epstein's low leader Express excuse me
over to Africa to do uh you know
foundation work that they were doing
there but they were also eating brains
maybe probably who knows at this stage
but uh Jeffrey Epstein also had the
Boeing 727 it's one of the few airplanes
that you could actually open up the
hatch mid-flight it's one of the
favorite airplanes of a lot of
intelligence agencies because they're
able to get rid of evidence or suspects
or whatever they want as they're flying
in the middle of
uh
over the fly yeah and they could just be
over the Atlantic or the Pacific and and
get rid of whatever they want or jump
out or Escape so it has multiple uses
but this was that the the Boeing 727 is
the intelligence agency plan
so that's what he had that's what Chris
Tucker was in and there's photos of him
and Kevin Spacey uh and of course prince
Andrew uh Bill Gates is also uh noted to
be at the Mansion in New York City and
the mansion in France there was also a
lot of international Donald Trump
um Trump's known to have partied with
him uh in the 90s but then there was a
dispute between them and Trump was one
of the few people that actually
testified and participated with with the
prosecution against him but he still did
party with him for a number of years
visceral footage of them like dancing
together hanging out but then what what
The Story Goes The Story Goes I guess is
that when Trump found out Epstein was
trying to Mac on young girls Trump was
like get that out of my building I
haven't seen that collaborated but I did
see the one thing is the one of the
lawyers coming forward and saying Trump
was the only person that came and
actually helped us uh fight for the
victims so that's the only thing I saw
protecting Trump I didn't see any kind
of evidence of what you're mentioning
because I don't know I see memes about I
don't know yeah the meme is that Jeffrey
Largo and he got kicked out of
Mar-A-Lago uh for doing that I haven't
seen verification of that I haven't seen
any evidence of that hearsay from what
I've seen the official narrative I guess
guess what the Epstein stuff is that he
was like luring wealthy people there
trick like yeah trick like bringing like
16 year old 17 year old girls and then
filming I'm like I got you and you're on
film now and then blackmailing them yes
his New York City Mansion was
essentially a surveillance Mansion they
had a room dedicated that had all the
monitors and all the cameras because
every single room including the
bathrooms had secret cameras wired in
everywhere so they would bring in
um what's his name what's that uh that
older movie director Woody uh well yeah
Woody Allen they would bring in Bill
Gates is also rumored to be there a lot
of very powerful people are also
mentioned to be there I think it was
Eric Weinstein that actually talked
about being inside of that Mansion as
well
um that or he said he yeah was he there
like Stephen Pinker was there and uh
everyone's saying oh yeah yeah I think I
heard that yeah but then but then when
the FBI came in there they openly talk
about oh yeah you know we we got you
know the the video footage there's
there's a bunch of cameras with
politicians uh and a bunch of tapes with
politicians names on it
um and they were like yeah we have all
of that but yet we have not seen
anything done because of this they're
probably about to release that book
though right sure any day now yeah well
I remember when they were rating it and
they were coming up with this like black
book they called they literally called
it a black book they're like oh my gosh
we found this and I was like okay so
what's in it because that's pretty
important I think that this worked
because misery loves company once you
get someone you're blackmailing then
they're like oh my gosh you have to go
over to Jeffrey's because we have fun
over there I'm in trouble I want you to
be in trouble too we're on the same boat
well think about it if you're Bill Gates
and he's got dirt on you you're probably
sitting there thinking I better get a
lot more people in that book so that if
I go down they go with me the idea being
the more people that he's gotten his
book the less likely the exposure is
yeah there there's a lot of black male
operations that are happening within
Washington DC we know that for a fact we
know that for for many recorded
instances not just with the Epstein
incident but if you're dealing with a
lot of money or a lot of power obviously
you need a safeguard to keep people in
line and what better way to keep someone
in line is to bring in a 16 year old a
17 year old and have surveillance
cameras there and say Hey you know you
cheated on your wife hey you got drunk
and did this hey we have this we need
you to vote a certain way we need you to
make sure that these people get their
way here when it comes to implementing
this policy here and this is where a lot
of people have a lot of theories
especially when it comes to Joe Biden
especially with what his son uh made him
as a contact in his own phone right yeah
I think that I I actually just this just
occurred to me I feel like this is going
to not work anymore as we gradually
begin to accept this particular sexual
proclivity as we're seeing in the
schools right now well that it could be
one of the reasons why they're trying to
normalize it because all the top people
in charge are like oh crap they're gonna
get me unless we normalize this yeah so
what's going to happen is in like it's
going to be 10 years and it's going to
be like the Supreme Court passes a
ruling maybe like 15 years
legalizing you know child abuse or
whatever and then 20 30 years later
there's going to be historical records
where people will be like man you know
they they came for Epstein destroyed his
life and he's a hero to the cause that's
what they'll say about him but think
about how like if we look back on the
past there are a lot of people that you
know during their day were not good
people and then later on we look back on
as like wow they did they did really
good things you know like the I should
say there's a controversial figure and
then the bad gets washed away if their
ideology ends up winning so that only
works if they end up winning because I
don't think they're gonna win but I
don't think so either because the the a
lot of this stuff is a self-solving
problem like leftists who are you know
trying to push this stuff well they're
more likely to abort their kids and
sterilize them yeah so just over a long
enough period of time math dictates
conservatives or there's gonna be more
of them put yourselves out basically
yeah especially with school choice and
homeschooling and micro schools I just
think it's an inevitability that you
know what I think will happen is in 50
years there's going to be a bunch of
like 80 year old Millennial you know
Millennials and they're going to be
super woke with like their hair shaved
and pink and tossed over and they're
going to be like we need to fight white
supremacy and then the younger
generation is going to be a bunch of
like collared shirt Christians of all
different backgrounds being like okay
Grandma
and they're gonna say like man old
people got crazy backwards views man
that's already happening I feel like uh
the younger generation is definitely a
lot more conservative than they were
when I was 20 years old definitely why
do you think that though uh I uh the
pendulum swing is getting quicker and
quicker and quicker until maybe it
slowly just all a straight Direction
forward that's just complete chaos I
mean because you know when I was in
middle school or whatever it was
definitely a conservatives that were
trying to stop our rap music and video
games and whatnot and
um then as I was in my mid to late 20s
it became like the woke leftists and
then seeing younger people it's just
pushing back against whatever the powers
are at the time that's what creates
conservative conservatism and then
leftism in the first place it's like
it's like the pain you said the pendulum
swing yeah so yeah the the millennial
generation is really annoying and they
don't want you to have fun and they
don't want you to laugh so then you get
people who are gen Z and younger being
like dude you're lame leave me alone
yeah I remember they were trying to ban
video games they were trying to ban
Grand Theft Auto they were trying to ban
music they're trying to ban artistic
expression and they were like these guys
are lame these guys suck uh but it
really makes you wonder about how you
know Society changes so quickly
especially on party lines and you kind
of Wonder is is it me who who changed or
did something else change
when I was in high school uh I really
loved George Carlin as yeah probably
most people in high school do and then
when I got to be about 22 I found out
that George Carlin had somehow become a
problematic comedian because he was
saying he was defending the idea that
you can make rape jokes for instance and
oh yeah Mouse raping a deer yeah it was
a Porky Pig and Elmer Fudd
and and I was like no I think yeah it's
like he should be able to make that joke
and I'll the the Facebook uh attacks on
I was like whoa okay things have
definitely shifted without me really
even seeing what happened here how old
are you uh 32. oh okay so so with your
YouTube channel now do you does your
viewership skewer younger
uh it seems like it's it's kind of Aging
with me like most people earlier on I
had a younger viewership but they're
probably all same age as you getting
older no like 20 ish now like the
majority of them growing up I kind of I
kind of think so I mean we saw the
polling from Hugh that showed gen Z is
slightly more conservative than than
Millennials but they're still very
similar in their political views and
that may just be because I think you
know I think we're all Millennials here
and we're all not necessarily
conservatives all Lydia's conservative I
am but we're like we're called according
to the mainstream left conservative
simply because we are not in a cult in
their cult so maybe that's why a lot of
people who are who are gen Z think they
might be on the left and say that and
then they also a lot of them might think
they're conservative because most of
them are probably middle of the road
moderate and just don't believe in the
weird cult BS yeah so you know how CNN
thinks that they're the resistance I
think that gen Z is looking at that and
they're like a bunch of Boomers you're
not actually the resistance this is the
resistance is being conservative and
thinking straight and maybe wearing a
collared shirt call me crazy imagine
wanting to be like Jim Acosta I'm
thinking you're the resistance
couldn't be me yeah we like you know
we talk a lot about
culture jamming and stuff we created a
an email account for our rooster Roberto
Jr you can email them with questions
Roberto Jr timcast.com does he answer
yeah the portrait behind you no that's
not that's someone else's chicken that
was a painting I just saw and I had to
get it because it's a chicken you have
to replace it now
well uh you know when we get a painting
of Roberto Jr we'll put it up uh
tragically Roberto Jr's mom died
Katarina and we're concerned there may
be uh it was cancer but there's a fear
that it could actually be there's a
disease among chickens that causes
tumors so hopefully that's not the case
but you know you know anyway what were
we talking about before you get an email
for this rooster oh right right at least
for one week yeah we did and my point is
just that like we just kind of do weird
stuff because it's funny
and the stodgy CNN types and woke types
just are not fun it's it's just how can
you possibly have fun when you're
walking on eggshells all day I have we
have people come here and they're
hanging out and they'll say something
like oh I was making I was gonna make a
joke but I don't know can I say that and
I'm just like bro you can literally say
whatever you want like I don't I'm not
gonna
just don't you know I don't know I feel
that way more about when I'm hanging out
with uh Millennials than I do with Gen Z
really yeah I I like you can say
whatever you want I feel like like I
don't have to necessarily hold back as
much because I know gen Z still has a
like they have a sense of humor they
kind of were bred into they they do not
like Millennials and how lame and uh
sticklers dodgy yes dodgy that they are
but like Millennials it's like I'm not
saying anything unless I know unless I
hear them say it first oh no no right
right so I thought you meant that you
feel more comfortable speaking freely
with Millennials oh yeah no yeah right
oh yeah no wait I mean like yeah I think
they're just watching us uh have these
conflicts and they're like what are they
doing they're like watching us like a
theatrical kind of state right yeah
we're in our own world people are doing
and they almost are just witnessing it
like and they they come off as more you
know gathered emotionally because they
don't want to play that game that's like
what the um old people are doing right
I'm not like in those Millennials I'm
hip you know I like uh Billy eilish you
know I'm the bad guy you know what I'm
talking about gen Z they don't like take
the bait like Millennials do like we are
so over corrected yeah um that we we
just demoed some behavior and they're
not impressed with that either so they
got to see how you know reactive we are
well I don't I don't know I don't I
don't know if we fall into that that
camp like we here obviously Millennials
as like a large group are just genuinely
bad in a lot of ways I think and um you
know I think I'm seeing more from gen Z
that they're funnier they're more chill
you know Millennials just kind of um
created the culture that that gen Z is
just repelling and it really is like
that it's just it's like look at these
lame people like they don't know how to
have fun all they know how to do is uh
destroy things rather than yeah and
obviously there's exceptions but
yeah what do you think you think the
most Millennials are just just really
awful
um I do I think Millennials Millennials
you know it's it's a it's a terrible
generation Jen Jen I like Gen X I love
Jenna Gen X are relatively chill but
some of them are pretty bad like every
generation that's bad people it's not
it's not about like how old you are but
there's like actually I think boomers
are actually really great I think
Boomers have done some things that are
really bad uh acquiescing uh or giving
into and capitulating to is probably a
better word the woke nonsense for
Millennials gen xers kind of get lost in
between but Boomers gave us uh the Next
Generation you know Star Trek my problem
with Boomers is they're supposed to be
these wise sages that are guiding us
it's like we're in this information age
and there's all this information but
there's no wisdom it's like they're
supposed to be the ones coming and we're
supposed to have you know some sort of
like roam these sages to look up to and
we have none of that like there are
there isn't any we're so we are just a
generation that's out here floating we
got Jimmy Buffett
Margaritaville yeah yeah that's true
yeah George Carlin what generation was
he was he was he silent
the thing about the Boomers though is
that they were their brains were riddled
with [ __ ] uh LSD lead and LSD yeah
break dust yeah brake pad dust yeah
George Carlin was part of the silent
generation 37. no there was a huge
impact when it came to uh lead the that
they put in the gasoline that lowered
the overall IQ levels very dramatically
there's still a lot of lead in a lot of
soils so you guys should always check
here
actually I did I did read about a guy
who ate soil like he would get you'd eat
it because it's just like organic matter
I guess but it's not a disease
mineral deficiency or something makes
people compelled to do that I noticed
that whenever we took the lead out of
the paint that's when they fluoridated
the water yes
the fluoride was what like 1900s like
early 1900s and the lead and the pain in
my hometown the my earliest memory of
NPR was being in the back seat of my
friend's car and hearing them trying to
get um people in my hometown of Wichita
Kansas to vote to fluoride the water and
they had this big you know divide two
propaganda did you hear about how they
want to put lithium in the water now
yeah yeah keep everybody from being
depressed yeah make them dull Vox wrote
that perhaps we should medicate everyone
well you know what that means that means
that they're going to come out with some
study that says of how much lithium is
already in the water from like you know
waste or people flushing them yeah
there's already a ton of prescription
that's framing Yeah Tim you just said
don't eat the don't eat the the grass or
the ground don't drink the tap water
more importantly than anything else so
what Vox did was they said in areas that
have higher deposits of lithium in their
groundwater suicide rates are lower it's
true so we should put lithium in the
water because it makes people yeah I
guess that's breaking the world yeah if
the government if the government really
cared they would put magnesium in there
and solve a lot of medical problems at
the same time but they're not doing that
very very small but hold on they're
putting byproducts of chemical waste
inside of our drinking water in order to
poison and dumb us down I think that
that's that people say that's a
conspiracy I think that's a legitimate
reason
conspiracy is intent yeah we know what
we know is they do put Florida in water
right we know that fluoride ingested
over a long period of time lowers IQ
like there's a bunch of studies about
that we know that it can cause high
amounts of fluoride can cause Dental
fluorosis so those neurotoxins these are
people who have the spotty brittle teeth
and so it's bad the question is if the
issue is that drinking what do they say
fluoride makes your teeth better if
you're older I heard that was the
argument so they decided that we should
ingest it that's why I shower with it
because yeah I mean like you know I
don't I don't well there's no there's
different fluorides there's there's one
that of course is a chemical byproduct
and another one that is actually natural
so there's a big difference between the
two and when the government puts it in
your drink of water they're not taking
the natural uh fluoride a chemical
byproduct that's why Mercy question is
intent are they doing it to make you
dumb is the conspiracy theory the fact
that they are doing it is a fact hmm
well yeah they they knew it when they
it's so toxic of a substance as it's in
these big mechanic you know these big uh
Vats that they have to not even touch it
in these hazmat suits to handle the
fluoride that they put in our drinking
water on purpose most rat poison is is
fluoride you know and this is why they
have a lot of warning labels especially
on toothpaste saying if your child
ingests this you automatically have to
go through poison control because of the
fluoride I thought it was strange they
left fluoride up to any type of
democratic process at all because they
just make all kinds of decisions and
they don't ask us they're not you know
why would they filling Us in they just
they want those those effects look at
what they've done to the diet and like
the the diminished fertility and
all these things that they that they
have done they didn't democratize us
asking for those things I feel like in
50 years people are gonna go to like an
antique store and they're gonna be like
whoa you have plastic bottles of Coke
that's crazy and they're gonna crack
open their glass bottle and yeah don't
trust any of that and even with with the
fluoride I heard another one that it
costs money to get rid of uh chemical
waste and so if you can find a utility
for it and figure out a way to sell it
uh rather than having to pay costs to
get rid of it I love that idea it's like
a factory producing Florida as a
byproduct yeah and then yeah and then
you have to say well either we pay a
fine to dispose of this or we figure out
how to sell it and by saying well this
is good for teeth and then you work
there's like an intermingling conspiracy
with or just give it to the government
for free yeah just imagine there's like
a factory producing a bunch of like
byproduct fluoride and they go to the
local town and they go listen here buddy
you're gonna make everyone's teeth
better just take a toxic waste and dump
it right in the water supply and then
you got to pay us and the guys like that
sounds like a good idea right I don't
know that's that's the one that I I
don't know if that's if I don't that's
that's I don't know I don't know if that
that's actually how it plays out we
don't even got to get the conspiracy
here's what I can tell you fluoride is
bad for you there's a bunch of studies
there was one it was like 10 years ago
it was an aggregate of a bunch of
studies saying that like IQ is lowered
by ingesting fluoride it's a neurotoxin
I was hanging out with uh I was hanging
out with my friend this is like 15 years
ago his sister had a kid and so I walked
to the kitchen and I see Nursery Water
have you ever seen Nursery Water oh yeah
and it says big letters with added
fluoride and then I just asked I was
like why are you giving your baby
fluoride and they're like she goes it's
Nursery waters for babies and then I was
like they put fluoride in the baby's
water and she goes they need Florida and
I was like no they don't and I I just
Googled fluoride for babies and there
was like Government website saying like
do not do this and I showed her and she
was like but why are they selling it and
I was like because people pay for it I
don't know like the government outright
said not to give it to your babies yeah
it's like whatever man and Floyd
predominantly is a byproduct of the
fertilizer industry so that's nice
that's something I'll say well I trust
the fertilizer
big big good people in there yeah big
fertilizer Keeps Us Alive guys that's
true I mean they do technically right
they do as big fertilizer is Russia by
the way but you know that's that's the
difference big fertilizer turns us into
the fertilizer a lot faster yeah yeah do
you think we're gonna get to that point
where they recycle human waste like they
like you you die and then they throw you
into them like you guys ever see water
world
yeah yeah yeah so like in you know Water
World's about it's the The World Isn't
that Costner yeah Costner and then like
there's like a floating city and what
they do is when people die they put them
into like this pit of goop where it
dissolves your body and they reuse your
organic matter because they don't want
to die you know I don't think they're
gonna
just a couple I just recall Bill Gates
drinking the water that was what toilet
water poop water poop water I figured
Bill Gates
and I'm gonna drink human feces and he's
trying to get other people to do this as
well that was definitely the uh
fraternal Illuminati type of thing
he had to do that publicly like I love
drinking poop why it's hazing yeah was
that before or after
um if you want to join the Illuminati
you have to drink human feces on
television I'll do it done or we release
the tape yeah
before after his exposure of being on
Epstein like visiting Epstein's uh place
it was after right um it was during I
think because he was he was with uh he
was friends with Epstein for a very long
time some people even speculate all the
way up until the 90s uh that they were
close together but they were such close
friends that his own wife says that she
divorced him because he wouldn't stop
hanging out with him whoa
the implications as to why Melinda would
have to split from that because like
yeah I know what you're up to yeah my
favorite was when Bill Gates was asked
about Epstein and he goes well he's dead
now so yeah right what does it matter
yeah
he's dead now man that was like crazy
cold but but it wasn't no it wasn't so
cold it was that like it he had this
like don't mess with me it was like it
was like the same way the way he said it
was like he was happy yeah yeah it was
flippant kind of you could see like like
he was getting frustrated I was being
asked about it you you had that it has
that painting uh Epstein had the
painting of George W bush playing with
paper airplanes knocking over two Jenga
Towers oh yeah I wonder what that
painting meant huh yeah
like what what is what is George W bush
with paper airplanes knocking over Jenga
Towers had to do with anything so weird
it's really strange somebody pointed out
something new about that rather recently
turned around because that wouldn't be
the side of the desk like it was huh a
strange place in Arkansas and he took
down one of the towers one of the towers
was down as he was playing with
airplanes oh the paper airplanes oh yeah
the implications are right there in the
painting George W bush used airplanes to
knock down the towers okay okay yeah
then there was paper airplanes yeah yeah
so I'm gonna pull up the photo now we
should probably post yeah it's a very
it's a very thought-provoking photo as
well as the Bill Clinton Monica Lewinsky
dress one was also very uh interesting
to say I love how Friday just turns into
Epstein yeah I did it I did it he
finally did it I just want to know who
painted those pictures I want to know
more no there's a woman who painted them
and she doesn't know how she got them
yeah this is an interesting point the
desk is turned around the chair is
behind it but the desk is facing the
wrong way
and Bush cue the image and Bush in this
painting Knocked Down The Two Towers so
you're saying that George W bush yes
used planes to knock down the towers in
this painting in this painting in this
painting exactly yeah yeah wow how
symbolic
that's crazy so uh I was rating the
woman who painted it she painted this
and the Bill Gates in the blue dress no
no the Bill Clinton I'm sorry I'm sorry
the Bill Clinton the Monica Lewinsky
dress that was the scandal of him of him
excreting his man juices on okay okay so
anyway thank you family friendly show I
read I read the same person painted both
and just sold them and did not know that
Epstein was the one who ended up buying
them what a weird thing to paint though
I don't know it's kind of to me whatever
you want like okay like all jokes aside
obviously we understand that the artist
was making a point about 9 11 and George
W bush but I don't think you know what
happens is Epstein has this and everyone
was like oh what does it mean was it no
no hold on it just means that someone
painted this to express an idea it
doesn't mean the artist believed which I
didn't had anything to do with it it's
just kind of like a funny circumstance
you had a lot of people who believe a
lot of things they painted a picture
about it Jeff rapstein ended up buying
it believe whatever you want to believe
well we don't know you know it's
important not to jump to speculations
but at the end of the day we don't know
it's why did Epstein like it so much to
spend his own money on acquiring that
idea it's the recognition
I'd have bought both of these these
paintings yeah that's they're they're
fine they're good paintings he probably
had a lot of other uh they're very
controversial they're very in your face
when especially when it comes to you
know just questioning narratives and
embarrassing people in power so you know
there's a lot of intent that you could
speculate just by these Bibles alone but
just like the art it's up to
interpretation if I saw the painting of
George W bush at a gallery I'd buy it if
I saw the Bill Clinton however I don't
know you know if someone was like oh do
you know that represents I might be like
oh okay but the the bush one I'd
actually put up yes because I think it's
funny Would you rename it Patriot Act
yeah maybe I don't know that's the plan
what's the name of it what's the name of
that piece I don't know Google it you
got a computer
you know I I just
uh there are things we don't know about
what they were doing and it's sad that
we only scratched the surface yeah you
know because I'd love to actually know
what was going on we only know one
percent of what was happening meanwhile
there's 99 of what we don't know
happening behind the scenes that
probably would blow our minds away if we
truly did understand what was happening
behind the seats of power I was thinking
about this you guys familiar with
fermi's paradox
the general idea is if the universe is
so vast and expansive and large there
must be aliens and if so why have they
not contacted us or why haven't we
discovered them
and then there's a bunch of hypotheses
proposed as to why humans have never
interacted with aliens and there's a lot
of them where like the great Zoo
hypothesis is that Earth is a zoo for
aliens they're just observing us and
then I thought about that and I was like
why don't we go a little further what
about like the great [ __ ] fighting
hypothesis that aliens don't just watch
us as a zoo they watch us to go to war
for fun and bet on who wins because I'm
like watching all this war stuff and
there's like the conspiracy theory about
aliens stopping nuclear weapons well
yeah like if you were watching like
roosters fight one of them pulled a gun
you'd be like whoa whoa come on like too
much too much but maybe that's it maybe
we're one big cockfighting ring for
aliens to watch while everyone knows you
don't bring a gun to a cockfight but
I've never understood
why the alien
alien Earth what
I know from science fiction you stop uh
nuclear weapons because there's
radiation that leaves the Earth and
actually destroys the potential
developing life on other planets so if
they were trying to raid life on
different planets and different
universes it travels forever well that's
the theory too specifically when it
comes to Mars that Mars was a former
planet that inhibited human beings that
was inhibited what do you mean that had
human beings
had inhibited potato you know what I'm
saying
because I thought you were saying that
something about Mars was inhibiting
growth of life now it is uh technically
but they're also finding the same
chemical only found in nuclear
explosions on Mars I forgot the exact
name of this chemical but uh yes
um it's it's a crazy Theory out there I
I I'm only scratching the surface at it
but but the same chemical that they only
found in Hiroshima Nagasaki in it
nuclear tests they found specifically
this rare chemical nuclear nuclear
nuclear nuclear uh they found those
specific that specific same element only
on the surface of Mars from from what
I've heard and seen also I just want to
also correct one of my other mistakes I
said Google sorry I I use Brave I use
brave brave browser here's the evidence
apologies for uh making another mistake
here evidence for a large anomalous
nuclear explosions in Mars's past from
h-o-u.e from usra.edu
Mars Isotopes Baseline Viking Lander
Mars meteorites I don't know I just
Googled this is what came up it's a
school it's got a bunch of fancy things
in it before it means it's right I
believe it I believe it hydrogen bombs
are boosted by fission of uranium or
thorium casing around 50 of yield is
fission this creates Xenon Isotopes is
that what they were referring to Xenon
I'm looking it up right now just to make
sure I have everything here but I go
deep down the rabbit hole and this is
like a rabbit hole that I went down a
few years ago so I'm now just refreshing
my memory of like oh crap you know
there's probably human beings on Mars
let's look at the evidence suggesting
this or even just like fragile life on a
distant planet could easily be wiped out
by small amounts of radiation that's
what Arthur C Clarke uh wrote about a
lot but also he's conspired to be a
Pito himself so we should nuke Mars oh
we should yeah every every planet with
nuke should fire every single nuke just
right at the North Pole of Mars why for
fun oh
see what happens it is another planet
yeah I don't care yeah we got this new
what do we got we got some uh 50 Megaton
icbms it was far off a couple of those
just tests just all of them all of them
no you don't gotta test them if they if
they bunk out whatever who cares is that
your plan to disarm the world of nuclear
weapons I think that's no no no no no no
no no no surprise we should be making
exponentially more so we can have a
consistent stream of just just bombing
the crap out of Mars Just Just
massive explosions just you know and
then we watch yeah well could we get a
satellite Norbit we watch and we're like
and we sell it on pay-per-view could we
bomb it so much that it turned into
comets then smashed into you know the
Earth the Fox News has an article about
this and so does the epoch times saying
uh this is the title here Tim evidence
of ancient nuclear explosion on Mars
says scientist
um and this is from an article in 2015
and that's probably when I read it yeah
and this is this is now coming to the
surface of like hey there's a lot more
of this than I actually thought why why
aren't you using Brave bro what are you
talking about oh my God my gosh Epoch
times evidence of ancient nuclear
explosion on Mars
says scientist continue reading for free
okay or I can just press the escape
button yeah
evidence of ancient nuclear explosion on
Mars nuclear reactions on Mars Earth had
to be natural this is from 2015. yeah
Xenon particles produce a nuclear
reactions surf of the red planet though
likely the result of two large anomalous
nuclear explosions on Mars in the past
argues propulsion scientist Dr John
Brandenburg in a 2014 paper titled
evidence of a massive thermonuclear
explosion on a Mars in the past on Mars
in the past oh well
when passed like how long ago yeah we
don't know is it possible that it's just
one of those things that's natural like
I know some planets have reigns of
diamonds is it possible that someone
fired a nuke at Russia just didn't say
anything and then studied it and then
when we sent the Rovers they found it
went oh it was a bomb it's like or or
like you were saying is it possible that
something that happened here with a
nuclear test went out and after what
does it take like 20 minutes for light
to reach Mars or whatever yeah then it
impacted something there yeah I don't
know when the when was the study but I
mean how long ago was the Tsar bomb
yeah 50 Megaton Gravity Bomb probably
leaves some some traces of residue on
Mars you know I was thinking
I was just thinking crazy stuff and I
was like
I was thinking about radio waves how we
don't see anything coming out of our
phone but we know it's there because we
can see the cause and effect and then
I'm just like what if in other
dimensions
the radio waves have a tremendously
detrimental impact
unlike other dimensions that other
beings live in and so just imagine if
all of a sudden you started feeling like
you're being shoved and like things were
slamming in your face and then in like
some other dimension like a higher or
lower Dimension or something somebody's
just like playing a game on their phone
and texting and then they use
things that interact with our Dimension
and theirs you know what I mean yeah if
that was the case I guess from just a
creative writing standpoint then we
would already be feeling those and come
up with our own understanding of why
that's happening who knows like
temperature or wind or something like
that I mean I suppose it would have to
be anomalous Oh No Maybe not maybe it
would have to be a pat there would be a
consistent pattern of of some kind of
you know reaction because they
constantly do it so like each and every
one of us has a phone that's working all
the time so whatever in this other
dimension is being impacted by that
would just see it happening and assume
it's a natural phenomenon
unless it started up randomly and like
hey all of a sudden around 2007 this
thing started happening you know what I
love about this is that none of us are
on any kind of alternative substances
right now all Alternatives yeah you know
what I mean no I'm what's what's what's
what's the opposite of alternative then
um Pro turn I have no idea that's not a
thing right normative normative I'm
drinking seed oil golden milk turmeric
in the seed oils but it has two work in
it it cures what ails you and the seed
oils yeah yeah right yeah but turmeric's
anti-inflammatory right so it balances
out you got the seed oils that cause
inflammation and then turmeric that that
levels that inflammation you know it's
like a speed it's like a speed ball
right where did you hear about the seed
oil stuff
um a whole bunch of different places
Blasphemous you eat murder Burgers
sometimes too murder Burgers no I don't
when I I don't know probably I'm just
guessing about me no way listen you know
you can't always be perfect but you can
always strive for Perfection you can
always this guy he's like don't drink
that coffee table it's got seed oils and
I was like bro like two weeks ago you
went to McDonald's I don't know what
you're talking about I have no idea you
might have mixed me up with somebody
else you went to Chick-fil-A like last
week I don't know what you're saying
that you get you get chicken chicken
nuggets all the time with all your
little high fructose corn syrup juice
you get the sauce how many sauces do you
get like seven no no you get like 20
sauces and you're like oh
hold on fructose juices there I think
everyone agrees that for every single
piece of chicken you need a full packet
of barbecue sauce do you see what I'm
talking see what I'm dealing with here
the lunacy and I get criticized reading
Chick-fil-A once I'm not the one who's
screaming about seed oils we could
always try to help hold each other
accountable at least somehow that's fair
so I'm not the one who like I pull I get
this coffee lucky Jack cold brew golden
tumeric whatever you're like look how
healthy it is I'm like read the
ingredients right now it doesn't say
seeds yes it does yeah
by this time next year you'll be soaking
sunflower oils it's coming for you
organic cane sugar
but it's got It's got turmeric in it
it's got black pepper in it that
surprised me really this is black pepper
makes turmeric work with other black
pepper a term I can't it's like the
action yeah for real yeah that's why a
lot of turmeric supplements have black
pepper in it black pepper is in all
those um like juice shots and stuff okay
Ginger and all that and cayenne and
lemon and yeah that's why all the it's
in there pepper and pepperon has some
kind of uh it's some kind of you know
feature I don't know what you call that
a feature but a characteristic of it
that makes stuff boost your metabolism
or something you guys know how like the
chickens are just like doing whatever
and have no idea what's going on up here
they got their chicken City with their
chicken Society their chicken food and
chicken friends you know what if that's
just us
right that's us we we we talk about
things like turmeric and we're all
really serious about it and it's about
as serious as a rooster going that's how
government views us is how you view your
chickens exactly they're like look how
they don't know anything this is silly
exactly look at their like happy and
content with voting obviously we do
whatever we want anyway and they think
they have something to do with it
democratically okay but what if what if
that's like what if they're aliens you
know and they just look at us like a
chicken coop and we're just dumb okay so
exhibit one is probably Nancy Pelosi I'm
just just saying there's a few people in
there that first she she probably has
two of them no I would say she probably
has two aliens inside of her don't do
that that are working together
no that's a good point yeah two big
aliens right here two big aliens right
like is there is there like a protrusion
or something that you can see on her
body where the aliens may be hiding they
have to be on the upper torso since that
makes the most logical sense okay that
these two protruding big Goblin aliens
are located right I feel like jellyfish
aliens yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah very
very strictly very very soft to the
touch
but yeah in some instances as well but
but also extremely flexible and and
moves around I told Luke before the show
that I did not want to talk about Nancy
Pelosi I'm just dying to like figure out
a way to interject it
I was waiting the whole show Linda I was
waiting the whole show I was like when I
kind of talk about Nancy Pelosi's
bizarre speaking of bazungas we have
this story nurse who was forced to quit
her job after being outed as an only fan
star reveals she's earned millions in
just two years as she shows off lavish
spoils from her raunchy career including
two million dollar mansion designer
closet and custom Porsche she's Ali Ray
she's 34. she was a nurse but she
figured out that porn makes more money
and so now she's Rich she's a
millionaire huh well there you go well
well yeah look at that disgusting now
she's an over-educated porn star I love
that is that what they said the role
play well she said she wasn't literally
an orange the role play the medical role
play could be so great on her Channel
but is that but you know I don't know if
that's overeducated that's just educated
because you know her work is an
exploration of the body and she's well
versed in the human body you know I like
it so what is this what does this mean
for like modern feminist thought that
she was a nurse but she's a millionaire
when she does porn instead so first of
all this tells us that pushing girls to
like educate themselves it's just a lie
because all you have to do is go on only
fans you could make two million dollars
the other lie here is that if you do
join only fans you will make two million
dollars because this does not happen 99
plus of the time yeah what's the average
that uh that a woman gets on only fans
it's like what uh I think it's 60 bucks
or 300 bucks a month on average yeah you
just got to be famous like when we see
these stories about only fans the
reality is some people you've got two
people that make music for some reason
someone's music gets it big and everyone
listens to it they may make money
because of it if you can attract
customers you make money and so that's
really it probably a lot of women who
couldn't do it so you want to go ahead
remember that one red-headed actress
that like made like a million dollars in
one like overnight or something because
she made it only fans and told her fans
that she was going to be naked on there
but she really wasn't but she grossed
all this money and it like crashed only
fans isn't that fraud well that's why it
was such a big discussion Bella somebody
I don't know Philadelphia
Rachel dalazar has an only fans this is
this is when you know the market is
getting very saturated and uh I can't
point fingers
yeah okay calm down well I'll remind you
you can make your only fans whatever you
want you can make it a cooking channel
if you want yeah you just it's another
path of uh you know generating income
online it's just another income stream
yeah but we all know technically correct
what it's for yeah and let's not kid
ourselves here yeah yeah I feel like
everybody knew when I announced that but
I was like no I'm gonna make like you
know polls about what you want me to
talk about and I'm gonna show a picture
of my actual cat who's amazing and I
love him his name you can't say you
showed a picture that's exactly what I
said I was like here's my cat there is
someone who does this they have an only
fans and they put stuff Julie perowski
oh is she does it and it's like the
titles are all suggestive but then it's
just like family friendly yeah she's
reading the Constitution or something
yeah exactly exactly talking about the
First Amendment she's great my
inspiration so that's so that so that's
it no no no comments on she's not a
nurse anymore
well I I admire her her pay upgrade
because I know nurses don't make that
much but I do think that this really
undercuts the whole case for girls going
even into stem because she actually did
what you're supposed to do and she's
like oh my gosh she's making much money
I'm just starting only fans and then I
think because she didn't only fans and
her co-workers found out she got all
this attention and that gave her the
leverage she needed to turn it into like
a really lucrative lifestyle what you
really want to see is a bunch of these
um e-girls that make all their money and
then they can go into whatever
philanthropic Endeavor they want you
know and go and do great things for
society because they have this career
that's so you know locked in for them
that would be it would almost be
Redemptive it's like so it's like Kim
Kardashian becoming like a civil rights
lawyer like something that she can
contribute that's not so like me
centered it's kind of crazy though but
Kim Kardashian doesn't do this kind of
stuff right she's not like posting porn
well no but I meant I would like to see
that format a lot because once you have
it made on the back of like doing
salacious stuff it's like now you're
free to talk about other things you
could go on and do productive things I
mean Kim Kardashian did get popular from
the coastline
that's why she's famous yeah that's the
only reason she's famous original you
guys we had this earlier there's that
politician in New York who made a sex
tape or whatever oh yeah that's gross
hey man you know the time's there are
changing are we gonna watch it yeah
we're gonna play it for the audience
live to review it let's review it that's
for the members only yeah the members
it's gonna be like mystery signs Theater
3000 or whatever yes where you can see
the back of our heads as we watch this
popcorn politician stuff yeah yeah
well there you go they should make a
video about how they're going to screw
the taxpayer in an actual score this is
never going to screw you buddy
that'd be great take it I love it
I could say a lot I could say a lot more
and I have a lot more parts but this is
a family-friendly show and I'm a
professional
does Nancy Pelosi's daughter
oh man
yeah what's Nancy Pelosi's daughter look
like oh let's find out who is her dog
what else I remember hearing about her a
couple of times didn't she work with Jon
Stewart or The Daily Show or something
like that
I don't know but where's that Hillary
Clinton yeah
she looks like Nancy Pelosi goodness
trying to find like a bigger picture I
guess they're all like really small not
great wow large Nancy Pelosi daughter
uh there you go is that one oh that's a
big one
that's a viewable photo there you go
all right she's taller humans have
gotten a lot taller look how much
different Nancy looks
yeah well you know that's a lot of
plastic surgery this is uh a lot of
people don't know this but um palanci uh
Pelosi
Pelosi actually had a a guest role in an
HBO TV show uh actually it was a long
running TV show it's called Tales from
the Crypt
it's a joke because I called it the
Crypt Keeper she doesn't like that to be
fair yeah she was very cute when she was
younger oh wait wait wait you know how
you do the Deep fake stuff oh can
someone deep fake her face under the
Crypt Keeper popping out of the thing
that would be great someone do that and
tweet it yeah maybe it does exist I'm
sure I'm sure that would be fantastic
her daughter is not very pretty but more
power to her I guess for being a lawyer
are you saying she shouldn't do only
fans is that I don't think anyone should
use only fans for the purpose that it's
typically used for that's just my stance
if that's your mom she can just snap her
fingers and put you in whatever role in
society you want to be I mean honestly
that's a free ticket to anywhere you
want to go no I don't know like if I got
a call from Pelosi and she was like have
I want my daughter on yourself I'd be
like no yeah but there's a thousand of
you I mean no offense I'm just saying
they'll find some other person that put
her on the show that does well no I know
it's just like but they're still
pigeonholed I suppose if she wanted her
to be like a manager at a chicken
processing plant she could do it she's
not too bad don't be hating Linda so to
be fair we already know we know that
women judge other people very harshly
like we've seen the graphs about how
they rate men on dating sites right I
think this this transfers to other women
as well just from my personal experience
for sure oh and she's look look look at
the picture from Wikipedia she's holding
a camera it's so that you know that she
makes movies she looks good for a 52
year old lady is she 52. yeah
she does look pretty good
for 52. so wait is Christy oh she looks
more like Nancy there we go
and she's not the one who's making
movies it's the other one okay there's
two is there like Laura and Christina I
don't know oh she produces documentaries
for uh her mother American selfie man
you know wow it must I just can't
imagine being part of a legacy family
like that I feel like it would suck
she's gonna win Oscars soon I mean
that's how all these peoples like are
built over time like we're talking about
CNN earlier and it reminded me how when
I was a kid in public schools they had
us watch uh channel one and Andrew
Anderson Cooper was like a young
journalist and that was like his first
gig so like if you're like a Vanderbilt
they just install you in like and see
how it was just like set up for Anderson
Cooper to be well you know after you
interned for the CIA yeah a little bit
Yeah Yeah but all of that stuff that's
just what I mean there's a different
level of access for these people that
are operating above everybody else it's
like whatever your child wants to be you
just you know give it to them on a
silver platter and hope that they don't
screw it up because nothing has any
value to them because they can have
whatever they want first they go to the
top schools where all the professors are
afraid to give them a lower grade then
they in turn at the Central Intelligence
Agency see then there again just you
know get a lucrative job that of course
everyone dreams of getting but it's
actually nepotism to the highest level
yeah think about the long-term priming
of that like taxpayers funded me as a as
a child to be exposed to Anderson Cooper
who would later be like the face of you
know the most trusted name in news I
mean that's that's a kind of like
unconscious priming of like making these
people celebrities so I don't think that
we should close this conversation about
the Pelosi Offspring without mentioning
Paul Jr because apparently in August
2022 suspicions were raised over
authorities Financial ties with
pelosi-led U.S delegation and that
included her son Paul Jr so there's that
that there's that bidenesque corruption
so it's everywhere well see this is easy
for me to see because I live in
Hollywood and I've done entertainment
for like I don't know 13 years or
something so like that I just watch I
just watch these like highlighted veins
of access to everything all the time and
seeing it in politics is is no different
well there it is
nepotism
I was I had a joke
that was going to lay up a layup for
Luke but I can't say it because you know
it shows family I have to I have to
censor 20 like 75 of everything I want
to say on this show yeah y'all keep
saying this is a family-friendly
shows
I didn't swear a little bit just a bit
yeah I did I I didn't know that was uh
one of the cardinal sins of yeah you
could never come back that's it it's not
that big families and friends the
chickens will attack you on your way out
that's true yeah yeah Chris is preparing
them right now that's true he has a
stick I've been wanting to see uh
chicken City from the inside in in
related context uh there's a video of
Biden sniffing on a child that just came
out like a new one a new one wow that a
child came out of the story came out the
video of the story came out
um that's uh it's very egregious well
knowing the Democrats a child may come
out soon soon after for sure
was it able
no child female
really yeah he like the video is going
viral right now on Twitter if you just
pop up Twitter it'll pop up right now
um and he gets handsy and uses the
sniffer are you retweeting it yeah just
now uh
uh yeah oh look at this
oh
you know what I love about Joe Biden
after the news came out that he was
grabbing and groping and sniffing women
they told him to stop he apologized and
then he kept doing it he can't help
himself
I can't remember the poor guy yeah it's
an automatically is everybody mad at me
this reminds me of showering with my
child oh
he's the president
how many tapes do they have on him oh
right
yeah but like the funny thing is I'm
imagining like Putin goes to Biden and
he's like
Joe we have camera on you groping young
girls and he's like he was like yeah
there's like 500 on the internet you
want to watch some with me good
time good memories man my favorites all
right we're gonna grab super chats oh
already if you have not already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends uh we got a bunch
of really awesome members only shows
over at timcast.com
so become a member and uh none tonight
but uh the cast Castle Vlog coming up
next Tuesday is going to be one of our
best we've got a great guest uh flying
in just for the show actually a couple
people have flown in just for the show
and uh it's going to be really great
with the uh yeah I don't want to spoil
it but I imagine they're gonna get
really mad at us over this one so it
should be great all right let's read
super chats what do we got here Raymond
g Stanley Jr says Gotta Love Friday
shows shout out to guest Lydia I think
there you go potatoes for Sheamus says
Luke I have an important question what
is a woman
uh someone who could get drafted who
can't get drafted into the US military
right now how
about Nancy Pelosi oh yeah she's a woman
lady
hybrid alien yeah yeah
Restless medic says my God I love Rusty
Cage the new song is by far my favorite
but only the family-friendly version
wink wink The Hearth song is up there
too because I think it has a somber
message
well I appreciate that Restless medic
Restless medic that's right
clef the misfit says thank you for
having Bitcoin mommy on tonight Jessica
Vaughn is the perfect woman and she
really needs to start her own podcast
yes thank you happy on and I'll join you
I guess let's go
Scott colom says anyone else noticed the
HBO watermark in the top right corner of
the Nancy Pelosi video that was
supposedly a CNN exclusive for just me
really was that there see that no yeah I
didn't see that either
I thought it was funny that they played
this did they really think that video is
going to help them
Nancy Pelosi being like I've been
waiting for the smile back to happen
it's like you were well that's really
weird huh how did you know it was gonna
happen
okay whatever maybe people are just dumb
gonna fall for it I guess whatever
all right knee boots says it's not
Pelosi's 4D chess it's quadruple D chest
oh there you go Luke you're welcome
thank you for that one I needed it MIT
form O2 says Ray Epps tipped off Pelosi
oh
oh perhaps possible perhaps wasn't he in
the video some people are saying that
yeah that he's like actually in the
video Cody May says 556-762 and 50 cal
yeah uh toggle says three served machine
guns and U.S armed forces 556 M249 a 762
m240 and a 50 cal M2 really the M2 full
full auto oh
mounted
J turbo says most crew served machine
guns in the US are m250 Cal or MK 1940
millimeter grenade launchers
it's still my bucket list to shoot one
of those that'd be so fun we were
talking about going down to Florida
because yeah one of our one of the
friends of the show has one that'll be
fun that's right that'll be fun hit me
up if you do
yeah
all right crafty says can the UFO spin
without the power of Ian I don't know
before I don't know what to do you just
hold the trigger down and it spins
there it goes
Ian's now replaced no
waffle Sensei says bold of you to
criticize The View Tim you literally
made a one for one copy with your show
chicken City
says hey Tim are you invested in any
funeral homes and can you get Ed dad on
the show would love to see the up to
date on the gbjb reactions hey wait a
minute ethereum and funeral homes are
good Investments right Luke no
absolutely horrible stop it why not
funeral homes though
well that's a different topic but you're
betting on people dying more than they
usually do which obviously there's a big
discussion we could have here about the
obvious that we can't talk about here on
YouTube
all right Andrew Patterson says no
notification Tim nothing in search had
to go to channel directly they're trying
to censor us well you got to be the
notification share the video
lunderwear says on your New Year's times
New Year's Times Square ads towering
over CNN you should have the slogan we
are the new era
I don't think people understand what
that means though and so we talked about
it like just doing a basic ad that says
watch Tim cast IRL Monday through Friday
at 8 pm Eastern Time
is the most powerful thing you can do
because people who see it associate you
with all the other big Brands and
it's a simple message that works I think
we should do an ad for CNN they need all
the help they could get and we just do
all their best best hits that we talked
about on the show just to highlight
don't forget CNN for black holes yes yes
eating brains yeah
yeah Raymond g Stanley Jr said don't
forget about the eating of brains there
you go that's right that's right there
yep yeah if anyone came up yep
evil zombie hamster says five bucks
because I appreciate you guys I listen
the next day on Apple podcast While I
Work miss you lids and I miss the potato
man oh I missed the potato man yeah
Sheamus will be coming back I imagine no
one cares about the potatoes oh man the
potato man
we gotta have we gotta have Sheamus on
with sticks for this episode 666. that
would be interesting that'd be fine yeah
yeah I would like I would watch that
yeah it'd be so cool and what we'll do
is we'll Turn the Lights real dim and
put candles up
and we'll all wear robes
Sheamus might be like no he would not
participate
in Ron production says hey Tim since you
love history my artillery unit will be
will be the Cedar Creek Battlefield for
the weekend for huge Civil War
reenactment stop by and we'll show you
show your people the candidates oh that
sounds really cool Cedar Creek
Battlefield where's that though because
someone look that up real quick is that
nearby probably so
fluffer boys 2004 says Tim I got it your
new News segment with the most accurate
name ever would be called No Cap for
real I love that first of all I'm on
board Cedar Creek is uh in Virginia very
cool how far is it from here
we don't want to tell publicly how far
we're away from specifications that's
not too far no worries relatively close
yeah I feel like everyone knows where we
are at this point Delta Charlie says I
was on deployment when the plane went
missing was sitting on the mess decks
watching and almost choked on my dinner
when that guest said that that's great
right even a small black hole could
swallow the whole universe it was a
great conversation holy cow wow
just leave me alone says I am 58 my
husband is 60. we cut off our cable last
year I watch you every every weeknight
alternative media rocks reality news
that is very very cool thank you very
much
yeah gotta get them while they're old
apparently that's right that's right
Andrew L he's the one who tweeted us
about Tulsi gabbard he highlighted her
tweet so ended up pulling it up and sure
enough it was there where she said I'm
honored to be selected as a 2015 ygl
voices representing Hawaii that's crazy
so whatever you know is what it is
Cynthia sponge says CNN was bad from the
start in the first Gulf War a dude
reported from a studio but green
screened a Baghdad hotel lobby yeah I
remember seeing that I don't know if
that's true though because I watched the
videos and I really tried digging into
that and I think it might actually just
be that it was really low quality
production and it looked fake but I
don't know I don't know it just it just
looks fake regardless of I don't know it
really does look fake was that around
when they started doing the 24 hour news
so it was like during that they started
24-hour news yeah yeah it was like you
know I was like around that period of
time maybe they were just trying to
figure it all out who knows yeah
all right Adept cuisinartis says shout
out to Rusty Cage one of my favorite
guests so far please invite discount
Steve Buscemi back soon
[Laughter]
it took me a while to get something big
guys that's all I I know I put on weight
so I would stop looking like him yeah it
didn't work
you should just tell people he's your
dad or your uncle yes he's like oh he's
my uncle uncle Steve uncle Steve just
tell everyone your real name is Rusty
basemi yeah
Brett ain't dead says not only on
Epstein Island The Man filmed on it
that's right that's true oh here you go
Mike Williams nailed it he says CNN
should be changed to con cable opinion
network.com
there you go or what what about like wac
you know no
so so uh I'm gonna I'm gonna have some
fun with this Luke would go around being
like I'm Luke from WRC and then I was
like where does the r come from we just
make it up just like we urge that I make
up on the show nuclear nuclear nuclear
nuclear there's people going crazy in
the chat room when they hear me say it
so nuclear we are changes wac yeah but
you don't want to go around saying hey
I'm whack
yeah WRC like screw it the English
language we're far superior than that
right now we make up our own language
all right Rudy C Winslow says my
favorite CNN moment is when Brian Selter
criticized Fox News staff for not taking
vaccine selfies yes that was so good
Sheamus did a cartoon about it where the
doctor is like but have you taken a
selfie and he's like no and he's like oh
why not and he's like I don't want to do
this and then the virus ends up getting
him you didn't take a selfie
no well man CNN what the
crazy
all right what do we have here
what's this
polara says so we have the old Linda the
new Linda a conservative cutie Steve
Buscemi and the Pierogi t-shirt guy Tim
you about done yourself damn right
pierogi t-shirt guy what do you make
pierogies or something I should you
should if anyone wants to start a
pierogi business with me without any
seed oils without any bad ingredients
let me know right now uh look at we are
change.org that's my email let's start a
pierogi company
beef liver mixed in with pasture-raised
cows pierogies
that sounds amazing let's do it Luke's
pierogies let's do it yeah I'll start it
up all right I'm doing it
but if I do this Sheamus has to start a
potato company because then you need the
potatoes exactly yeah that's right yeah
yeah Sheamus is potatoes yeah yeah
well there you go let's do it I mean we
we need a product to sell anyway why not
pierogies freezer perogies yeah yeah
perfect yeah yeah and they'll get them
in like what beef liver we'll get them
in you know Jewel-Osco and and Savon and
uh Pavilions I'm just trying to name a
bunch of different grocery stores from
the country we got Food Lion Safeway
there you go it's only going to be
polish Delicatessen stores like the
small ones there was one in my
neighborhood in Chicago I don't know if
it's still around it was called gilmart
and they had like the best potato salad
ever
but uh if it still exists and you're in
Chicago you can go check them out
everybody used to Rave over their potato
salad apparently it was like a big deal
if you're in the Pierogi business hit me
up
all right now that um we were talking
about starting a pierogi business Let's
uh see what we got Andrew Starr says you
guys must not be around very many gen Z
because they are nuts there are I I
there's probably a lot of bad ones you
know crazy ones but there's crazy people
in general yeah I never said that they
weren't nuts they're definitely insane
yeah
oh okay here we go dim some Nim sum says
oslan isn't a cannibal anymore every
seven years you have all new cells but
there is a video somewhere maybe in an
elevator of him meeting humans I heard
that yeah
so I guess after seven years you're no
longer accountable
all right I guess I always thought it
depended on the severity of the crime if
you
turn around and not be a cannibal
anymore right you can renounce
thievery and be like it was a mistake
I'll never do it again and people will
be like well he's he no longer does that
it was a you know he's a paid his due
but if you like eat a person you you
could never just like not have ate a
person you know what I mean it's just
more serious it's a social construct
yeah yeah that's fair yeah is a cannibal
Joe spinella says I'm a gen xer looking
down at you Millennials and gen z type
smugly laughing from my theatrical
balcony glad to hear it love it thank
you
Dan Pitt says I have all my fingers the
knife goes chop chop chop if I miss the
space beat in between my fingers will
come off was that your biggest song
that's probably the most uh culturally
significant because people stole it too
didn't they yeah I mean like the tune
who knows I mean people have like gone
back and like found other tunes that
sounded similar yeah but I I definitely
wrote it from my head but yeah now it's
like definitely uh been become popular
on Tick Tock 27 million views on YouTube
is that where it's at yep yeah not to
mention there's a bunch of other videos
like copying it or playing the song too
you know right yeah
Mart arbenflart says don't eat dirt Tim
good advice oh here's a good one crispy
Joe says CNN should be called CNN
cannibal News Network there you go yeah
yeah then I would watch
your heart out oh no Luke you know I bet
if they leaned into the cannibal thing
their ratings would have gone way up
yeah it's like they they look it's it's
such buzzword that it's been like 10
years we're still talking about it
imagine if they just actually put him on
as an anchor and said look if you just
do the show while eating people
people are gonna watch and you know as
long as the people being eaten consent
to it I guess was it there was there a
story about that where like with the
Kevin Bacon guy no was that what
recently recently somebody was in the
headlines for like some some guy that
looked like he was in the original
Donner Party come back to life and he
was eating a guy named Kevin Bacon
yes I did yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
know no there was a story on that part
there was a story where two guys met up
because one guy consented to being oh
yeah yeah very weird in Germany this is
Germany this is uh I think it's like
last Miss mivas yeah Rammstein made a
song about it yeah they did really yeah
it's a famous game like though I think
it's in the late 90s did the cannibal
not look like a Donner party like
Remnant I don't know about that I don't
remember but I just know that it is
something my this m-e-i-video or
m-e-i-w-e-s I should say I think if
you're in a crisis situation like the um
like the Donner party was that if you
have to eat a person to stay living then
like you shouldn't have to be called a
cannibal like that was like yeah you
know you are sorry not you're cannibal
like yeah well I mean you are a cannibal
right but like should you have to is it
the same as people who are just demented
that wanna because you have this will to
live right and if it's a dead person
that's there lying there and those were
the only people that well right but like
this the stigma attached to that did I
tell you I used to be a Democrat for my
whole life well no I mean like we can we
can we can understand why someone would
do it but doesn't change the fact that
you're a cannibal yeah okay well but if
you are a vegetarian are you still
considered a carnivore because you used
to eat meat but that's different a
carnivore isn't something you earn based
on like having committed an act one time
a carnivore or uh humans would be
omnivores it's just a classification of
like what we can eat you see how that's
just like us like a
a social construct of something because
we're just picking and choosing what
well no it has lasting humans humans are
omnivorous no matter what always you can
stop eating meat and say you're a
vegetarian and then you stop being a
vegetarian when you start eating meat
again like having committed an action
that we we have like a I guess a name
for
I I guess you know like I said it's
based on severity and eating other
humans is pretty severe like it's up
there I think that if you are like a
daughter that's true I think if you are
in the Donner party and you survive
because you had to eat one of your
compatriots you don't care what they
call you because you're still alive and
you're very young yeah they like one of
the guys that came back from that all of
society because of course Society was
very small um in the 1800s but um they
like they like blacklisted this guy and
he got ran out of town and he was he was
shunned his whole life for something
that was obviously just a something how
did they find out
well because there was all these
accounts and they have the whole reason
it's a piece of history is because
there's all these like journals you know
no I know but like imagine admitting to
that and then destroying like um it's
it's there's no internet there's no
video footage no one's filming
I know that's what I'm saying once they
got rescued they had to account for why
everybody's dead right right and so it
froze to death well and starved the guy
how did you survive what did you eat
rabbits and what we did was we cracked
their bones I got the bone marrow for
fat we barely made it we're so yeah well
they had all these journals of all these
people's property and all you know they
abandoned some along the way I mean it's
a it's just there was hundreds of people
in the original Donner party all those
cats you know he was a loud mouth
McGillicuddy yeah they spilled all the
beans
so the funny thing is we we know the
story of the Donner party but I'm
willing to bet there's like 800 000
identical stories that we've never heard
I mean there's that story from uh the
rugby fans remember this the story from
Peru I don't remember what the team was
or whatever nationality was the soccer
players
I feel like it was rugby for some reason
maybe wrong but they were they all crash
landed and they had their plane crashed
in the I don't know somewhere in the
Andes and then they had to eat there to
see the whaling ship the Essex that uh
Moby Dick was based on from Nantucket
they went out 19 people and three got
back and the rest got eaten yeah wow
yeah and then here's the thing if you're
plane crashes and then it's like you and
a group of people and then everyone's
getting really hungry
and then some one person is really weak
and like I'm not gonna make it and then
dies everybody looks around and they go
we have to eat them otherwise we'll die
and then you say I won't do it and they
go okay and then three days later it's
you going I'm so weak I'm gonna die and
they're like then you're next the
problem is with starvation is the people
who die of starvation have uh the most
lean meat on them so they're the less
nutritious so that they're actually not
going to keep people alive longer you
want to eat
the problem with that is the ethical
line is did I murder you to eat you
that's much worse than being accountable
because of you know this situation
did I kill you to eat you that's
obviously way worse you need a dead body
like I do not want to be in an airplane
with Raza Aslan
wait rather it's been 30 minutes he's
putting on a bib and pulling on a fork
and a knife and he's like excuse me as
the plane's going down and like calm
down stop it I say we eat that guy no no
actually if we were gonna make it a
movie the plane would be going down and
then it crashes and then rezla debates
how he has to eat people and then at the
end you get the the reveal and it's
rezla walking up to the plane before
takeoff and like cutting a wire and then
going
and then it's like oh it was him the
whole time he wanted to eat people you
gotta eat all right Nate says California
and Washington already legalized
composting human main so we're already
there somebody tagged me in that during
the show and I was like I thought we had
like a couple years at least I guess not
I'm screwed
it's gonna be funny man user not
available
there you go yeah I don't know about
Netflix Netflix kind of suck it's gonna
be Amazon
yeah it's gonna be something that's
gonna video games and Drugs That's What
Noelle Ferrari uh yeah Schwab's right
hand man says it will be so there's a
bunch of AI programs I don't know if
you've messed around with them we're
messing with stable diffusion it's so
fun making these photos but also there's
a uh the the open air playground you can
type in tell me a story about and
whatever so I actually I tweeted a bunch
of these I was like tell me a story
about Donald Trump saving the world and
then it literally just writes the story
out here's the craziest thing
I did this I posted in our slack Luke so
I'll show it to you I said write a
script about Luke gradkowski explaining
how Russia starts World War III and it
wrote a we are chain script it said hey
everybody Lou gradkowski here from we
are change right now Russia I I was like
Whoa man this is like welcome back did
it do that no it said I'm Luke Krakowski
if we are changed I didn't prompt we are
change it knew who you were and it wrote
it out so what's gonna happen in the
future when you plug in the neural link
I said this before you're gonna set
you're gonna you're gonna plug into the
Matrix the neural link you're going to
be in just it's white nothing and you're
gonna go create a world where I am the
general of an army fighting against
Russia and I have super powers like
Superman and then the world is going to
manifest right before your eyes and then
you're gonna start flying around and
that's what they're gonna make they're
gonna give everyone the opportunity to
be gods in their own mini universes uh
if we're currently in that simulation I
definitely typed in the wrong prompt
yeah you did it's all your fault you're
like make me look like
give me a mediocre understanding of
random things yeah
yeah but enough to be like I mean look
man you got a big big YouTube channel
rather successful so I think you
probably typed in the right thing you
know you started the game and you were
like I don't want to be too famous but I
want to be like successful famous you
know have a lot of fans and uh it was
modest it was a moderate modest request
but you know you don't want to be too
famous it's annoying you can't go
anywhere you can't do nothing you don't
be like middle of the line like d-list
z-list
this mid plot like okay the ending isn't
written we don't know I appreciate that
true I like that Ryan James says next
debate on your show should be vosh
versus Dave Smith please make this
happen vosh needs a formidable challenge
Dave Smith will destroy also Coleman
Hughes would be an amazing guest he's
got great Insight on CRT I actually vosh
and Dave Smith would be a really
fantastic authorization I just think
it's like vosh is one of the only
leftists who is willing to come on the
show yeah because most of them don't
want to do it I would have to keep
myself out of that conversation if that
was a debate just to be neutral to vosh
you know yeah
but I I I wonder yeah I don't know
vash's position on war is he pro-war
probably
I would I would I would assume so just
based on General tribalism but I don't
want to I don't want to immediately
assume that he might be very much
opposed to it
I think he said some tanky stuff that
kind of thank you Vibe yeah yeah
definitely
Sean says Xenon is one of two common
fission products of uranium there have
been natural fission reactors in the
past look up fission product graph
retired Navy nuke very interesting
interesting very interesting indeed
Dylan Keller says what if religious
experiences are just a side effect of
higher beings texting each other and
they don't realize it affects us or that
we're here at all dude that's amazing
yeah
do you guys ever watch what the bleep do
you know do we know yeah yeah one of the
one of the best parts of it is when they
explain uh higher dimensional beings
and uh it's the flat land thing so for
those that are familiar the the narrator
basically says imagine there's a
universe that only exists in two
Dimensions you as a person in the third
dimension have a concept of up so you're
above this two-dimensional reality but
they have no idea what above or below is
it doesn't exist to them to you you're
looking down you can see the inside of
their house you can see the streets you
can see the cars you can see the people
so when you speak and your voice goes
down they feel your voice coming from
the inside of of their bodies because
it's like hitting the center of their
Mass which they can't comprehend and
then you say to them in your closet
There is five dollars in a shoebox
there's a map of Europe outside right
now as a dog he's gonna oh He barked and
then this this two-dimensional being is
going like how can you know all of this
are you God and you're like no I'm just
in another another dimension so it very
well may be that a lot of these
experiences I've heard so many stories
from people who say they've heard a
voice coming from inside their body that
that's like it may be something like
that do we know what the pulse the low
frequency pulses and Havana or
some people say they're fake okay but
maybe that's it maybe maybe the
international interdimensional beings
just got Wi-Fi and now they're just
blasting us and we're like ah my brain
that'd be actually kind of funny if that
were true the humming you're hearing is
that is like it's like a 17 year old
interdimensional being playing Call of
Duty or whatever they would call it in
their Dimension oh is that like people's
ears ring constantly sometimes
it's the aliens that's right you're
welcome I gotta read this one from real
Hydro because we know we love you man he
says I agree to him you guys do have the
brain and IQ of chickens finally we can
agree on something you may have you may
just have something Tim oh hi Joe I
appreciate it that was a really good one
I had to read it yep the brain and IQ of
chickens
that was good coming from the guy who
dumps money on the show to rag on it but
you know respect I appreciate the super
chats I mean you're saying the things
you don't like about us and you're
giving us money and that one was really
good credit where credit is due grafty
then follows up with
nice happening
not relevant says some notable lucasms
exacerbated vigilance possibility
tentacles metamol amazing durgatory
revelance tethering expulnation turmoil
peculiar
130 a hundred and thirty six hundred
thousand dollars a nuclear I'm creating
my own language guys you guys are
catching me in what I'm doing here love
it but uh yeah
so what what can you say English is not
your first language yes respect it all
right Guardsman says I asked a local
dentist about Florida in our water he
said no doesn't know about any mind
control stuff but he does know that
cavity appointments dropped off almost
entirely when they did fluoride does
help your teeth as far as I know that
doesn't mean you should swallow it yeah
yeah or base in it in fact you have to
go to the Poison Control Center or
something or like a hospital if you get
yeah if you ingest a bunch of toothpaste
it's like a warning on it yeah it's bad
I'm good so you know what's going on you
know YouTube is just so slow it's so
annoying I think we got a couple more
Super chats we can read here let's see
reggae Vibe says look up liver eater
Johnson a real cannibal whose story is
legendary his statue is in Cody Wyoming
oh I think that for some reason
all right what do you got here SR-71
industry says Shameless plug for SR-71
industry starting a channel for car
enthusiasts by car enthusiasts we will
discuss budget builds and turbo installs
even in the apocalypse car culture
Reigns witness me uh I don't know if we
ever announced that we are building ski
bowling did I ever mention that
not officially yeah because because
someone's probably going to do it but I
don't care because I want it to exist I
want you to imagine this a bowling lane
but at the end of that bowling lane is a
ski ball Target
ramp so you throw bowling balls they
launch into the air and then you try and
get them into the points yeah I think
that's an awesome idea yeah so we're
actually working on it right now but
we're probably several months out
because freedomastan uh the building
just got finished finally but uh that
just means the outer shell so now the
internals have to be done lighting
um and one of those things we want to
build is a bowling lane where we can
fold down a ramp that serves as a
Skee-Ball mechanism do you have to have
lighter bowling balls for that we're
going to use probably wood like a really
light wood or plastic because you don't
want to throw a 10 pound bowling ball
and slamming into it but then the idea
is if you fold the ramp back we can
actually have pins so you can actually
bowl or you could skeeble but I'm like
I'm just saying I ski ball is so much
fun but so small I want full force like
20 mile an hour we're just slamming it
no it's probably too fast it'll probably
just smack the top or whatever but you
could do that ski ball ski ball too yeah
it would definitely take a lot of uh
physics experimenting to get that right
because yeah it would a lighter ball be
enough I don't know
it's Skee-Ball so you the lighter ball
only has to fall in a hole sure that's
it so uh it's actually not a lot of
experimentation it's just going to
require basic math we're going to need
someone to just draw out the math uh and
and and Big Balls yeah make big balls we
need someone who can make really big
balls who's someone's got big balls so
it's it's basically
if it look in skee ball if you throw the
ball too hard it just smacks the top and
falls down you get nothing it'll be the
same thing for ski bowling you know
you'll have to learn how to throw it at
the right speed to try and launch it
into the targets to get 100 points 50 40
30 20 or 10. I'm really excited for ski
bowling it's going to be really really
fun I look forward to those videos for
sure if you haven't already my friends
please smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member over at
timcast.com got a whole bunch of awesome
uncensored shows Monday through Thursday
every night 11 pm and that library is
massive so don't forget
to check those out you can follow the
show at timcastirl you can follow me at
timcast Jessica do you want to shut
anything out uh please follow me on
Twitter and Instagram uh Jessica Vaughn
oh and it's so exciting to be here in
the room like where I've been red pilled
for the last time there you go uh life
is a video game and I feel like this is
definitely one of the boxes to check so
right on yeah thanks for having me Lydia
have you anything to shout out I do have
a few things to shout out my marketing
directory is telling me to hammer three
things first of all I have a YouTube
channel it's at Sour Patch Lids which is
surprises no one the other thing that
might surprise people is that I do have
and only fans it's called Lids of tick
tock lyds and Sour Patch let's stop me
that's all thanks so much for having me
I'm very grateful to be here right on
and Mr rusty cage uh go check out my
YouTube youtube.com forward slash Rusty
Cage I think you will be pleasantly
surprised at what my current project is
he built a lemonade stand yes just a
lemonade stand just a lemonade stand it
might not just a lemonade stand just a
lemonade stand there you go no don't say
anything else
I'm gonna have to watch that one it's
good my website is Luke uncensored.com
if you think I Get Ridiculous here just
imagine what I do behind my own private
website where I get to say and do
whatever I want videos there almost
every single day a forum master classes
exclusive merchandise I uploaded one of
the videos on a on a fake YouTube
channel automatically taken down I
wonder why lucansensored.com see you
there yeah see you guys in the chats
this evening I guess you know the chat
the comment and uh talk to you later we
will see you all next time I guess we'll
have Clips up throughout the weekend and
I really got to stress this become a
member because Tuesday at 7 pm we are
going to have one of the best cast
Castle episodes ever we've all been
working very very hard on it we've
brought out two really awesome guests of
course Rusty's here he's going to be a
big component of the new show so we're
really excited to have him and we've got
another guest I'm not going to name but
you'll you'll figure it out obviously on
Monday so uh thanks for hanging out
everybody and we'll see y'all on Monday